jesus [ __ ] christ
yeah i restarted the router and it says
the um
it says the stream health is excellent
well like i said for now
well before it was just said that no it
was yeah we got
yellows yeah we got like four so it may
have been that the router needed to be
reset
just nobody moved and i hadn't reset
that router in
several months that's true so maybe
that's what it was we'll see
i don't know wolf maybe we'll figure it
out what i was talking about as i was
talking about before it dropped
i said a lot of those chain restaurants
will give you a bunch of extra food to
try to bait you back in
yeah later on like oh i got a good value
but really all they gave you was
half a handful of extra french fries and
maybe a couple little sides like a
couple pieces of bread they didn't give
you really anything
well they did but it wasn't in terms of
money it wasn't really worth much
but uh chantelle's she was giving it
stuff
you know it's homemade that's good stuff
you know man
she was like oh for a couple extra bucks
would give you a big old [ __ ] side of
catfish
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
protein there man oh yeah well like i
said i didn't realize that it was going
to be like a big pile of shrimp and a
big pile of fried catfish
yeah i just thought i don't know i just
thought it was going to be like a
smaller
wall but and then you know i wanted to
take i wanted that to serve wanted to
taste her homemade desserts not not the
stuff i know she's buying out
yeah the cakes i had the cakes they're
great but i want to see what she made
and she's making nana put it in cobbler
that's southern stuff
you see if you want to support a
restaurant you always want to get drinks
and you want to get desserts because
that's their profit makers right there
i feel bad i never get soda because i
don't like soda drinks
i just don't drink it i always get ice
water with lemon in it you pay a couple
dollars for a drink
they paid five cents for that well yeah
that's kind of like
okay there's a huge profit margin every
restaurant like fast food restaurants
and everything
but like i said i don't i never get like
if i go to a fast food restaurant like
mcdonald's or something
i usually get iced coffee i don't have
soda i'm just not a big soda fan you
know
you paid five bucks for a big old nana
pudding
you know she paid 30 cents for that i
want to get her give her that money but
i want
i want that pudding too i want that i
want that pudding i want that
because you know i can i can make it
here but then i have to lay out [ __ ]
20 bucks to make a big old bowl of that
[ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean maybe only use
half of it
bananas wafers
half a box sometimes a whole box
depending on how big the tub
is you're gonna make that well yeah i
feel like if you're gonna make nana
pudding you gotta
make it it ages well after it's been in
there for a couple days all those
all those [ __ ] wafers start to
absorb [ __ ] moisture you know they
get soft
i like somebody was in there talking
about they want to taurus
that taurus i think he said tx22 i'm not
sure exactly what that is that must have
been
one of the little sub compact 22s i
don't know if that's a target or a sub
compact
22 is fun for target shooting light game
you know
having fun training but uh
you don't want to have a self-defense
[ __ ] no
380 or bigger that's it
yeah sandra what's the name of that
putting nana putting yeah
within yeah taylor said yep nana's and
banana
yeah in the in the cookbook i called it
nanner pudding
yeah dan it's in the cookbook
yeah yankees and shittle make the
mistake of calling them vanilla wafers
it does not
save vanilla wafer on the box it says
nilla wafers with an n
that's the nabisco brand yeah you gotta
kind of use those they do have generic
ones but they're not grill away
they're not quite the same as the
nabisco ones yeah you want nabisco
nilla wafers and it's nana puddin
n-a-n-a nana we don't need no first
syllables
down here we just need the second
syllables
ginny doesn't like banana so she doesn't
yeah i'm not a big banana
fan yeah that's a banana fan banana
phone
yeah i don't i don't know why i've just
never been
i like i like a bunch of other fruit yes
i don't know i don't like but
i you know i can eat like a banana like
a real banana
but i don't like anything with fake
banana flavor
i do not like that artificial banana
flavor
[ __ ] no need for me too saying you
guys are killing me all the food talk it
always gets me eaten
yeah yeah well that was another thing is
i was going to say
if you go to a little southern
restaurant
or you know uh you know something like a
like a soul food restaurant which soul
food you know southern food and soul
food
it's the same thing pretty much pretty
much um
it's just one of the different versions
of southern food a lot of crossover
um in in southern culture
especially this includes louisiana
with cajuns and [ __ ] and creoles a food
is like a religion here
it is you really gotta watch it
uh like for instance my dad grew up
with a baby bottle that had milk and
[ __ ] bacon [ __ ] drippings in it
they
they used to put get that baby some
protein they would [ __ ] give that
baby some bacon fat
they would trick bacon fat in baby
bottles yeah
back then make them healthy you know
they just had different misc they had
different hair in your chest
yeah make that boy get him big get him
bigger
yeah [ __ ] crazy well that was very
yeah i mean my southern grandma was very
much even though she was like very thin
her whole life
yeah but that was just kind of like if
you were kind of chubby that was good
yeah just like yeah you need to get you
get healthy healthy
healthy yeah you know what i mean you
gotta be chubby and if you didn't eat if
you're if you just ate a little bit if
you didn't get seconds they thought you
were sick
yeah this whole thing about being thin
and fit that's that's
white upper class mentality you know the
southern
middle class or black people no in the
south though
it was is it [ __ ] up again it froze
it's just [ __ ] up again
well it didn't stop but anyway
[ __ ] you know having [ __ ] meat on
your bones was
considered to be that hey you were
eating well you weren't starving
you must have money yeah i feel like
that's kind of what it was like because
for a long time if you were skinny that
meant that you were diamond enough you
know what i'm saying
yeah yeah t says cholesterol off the
charts at five years old yes
actually when the cholesterol is off the
chart it's actually
on the southern chart yeah we have our
own
it got our own chart yeah
i don't know why your [ __ ] computer's
doing this it seems to be doing well
over here well i'm just going to pretend
everybody's having no i'm not having a
problem i'm just gonna pretend
that well my [ __ ] does that sometimes
where it's like my [ __ ] will freeze up
and then it'll just
my [ __ ] starts [ __ ] doing it but okay
i'm back now
back all right but uh god this is just
it's just stressing me out
geez talking about two yes nana puddings
and nilla wafers
they're round flaky cookies yeah
southerners enjoy sweet potato pie over
pumpkin pie but both are delicious yeah
they're both good
they're both i like pumpkin pie better
than than sweet potato pie
potato pies they taste kind of similar
man i [ __ ] want
i once mentioned what they were handing
out sweet potato pie
and i mentioned pumpkin pie says yeah
it's good it's like pumpkin pie
my dad's best friend who he grew up
william whitman looked at me like i had
slapped somebody
he was he went like that pumpkin pie
we don't we don't eat pumpkin pie around
here that's for y'all yankees
and then he put a gun in your face yeah
yeah that's for y'all yankees because
you call me a yankee yeah that's for
y'all
yankees we don't eat i wasn't southern
enough
that's for y'all yankees you know
because i was a traitor i've moved
around
you're supposed to stay right there in
your town
we don't eat no pumpkins here
he was serious too which is dumb because
pumpkins are delicious
it was so interesting he was mostly
[ __ ] with me you know what i mean
they don't have pumpkins there
you know whatever and it was kind of a
[ __ ]
it was kind of a thing of [ __ ]
cultural pride
yeah yeah northerners eat pumpkins we
don't we don't eat pumpkins here
we eat sweet potatoes that's like all
right
of all the stupid things together well
there's all kinds of little [ __ ]
oh i know it's dominance little [ __ ]
thing you see what you like nobody
people don't understand for you people
that don't live in the south
you just don't understand our
grandparents not so much our parents but
our grandparents
hated the north they [ __ ] hated the
north
northern people californians were kind
of like on they didn't really know what
to make of that
nowadays they wouldn't like them but
they
absolutely [ __ ] hated the north
i don't know i remember my grandfather
my grandpa died in 1990 yeah but yeah he
was very
back in those days yeah back in those
days back in
our grandparents days it wouldn't have
been safe for a northerner to walk
around
not not in the deep parts of the deep
south they'd kill you
they probably would have some areas yeah
they were tribal basically
you were the enemy i've been into this
many times over
in other parts of the shows it was a
north korean style mentality
they had lost to that war they didn't
give a [ __ ] about any of the
the politics behind it it was just this
honor of that they had lost that war and
they could not stand
being dictated to by new york and
chicago and northern people they just
[ __ ] hated them although chicago's
midwest they didn't care
anything that was outside the south
anything north of the
of the nation the the mason dixon line
was an enemy
that was one of the things i mean my
grandma wasn't so much like that
my grandfather totally was like i said
he died in 1991
um and that was one of the things i
never liked about growing up in the
south everyone's like so provincial
and i don't know it's just like they
couldn't just be
cool and be normal and just like hang
out with people like normal people they
always had to have like these kind of
virtue signaling markers that it's like
you know are you from here are you from
there
we don't eat that we don't do that i'm
like would you just [ __ ] chill out
it was right yeah it was most it was it
was more our grandparents generation
yeah yeah i think they had been through
a lot more
my dad wasn't so much like that he kind
of that kind of is
he was that my dad kind of is yeah he
was only like halfway like that
yeah you know he he he would like going
yeah
yeah they're [ __ ] up but he wasn't
real hardcore about it right
he could he could deal with a person
based upon who they were
you know what i mean yeah uh but no not
my grandparents
[ __ ] no especially my grandmother my
gran i never met my granddad
uh or her you know on my dad's side he
was dead by the time i was born
but uh my grandmother absolutely hated
[ __ ]
non-southerners it was like you were a
foreigner
worse yeah like i said i'm i'm familiar
with that
uh mindset sure yeah it was a different
time
it was yeah it's my dad didn't take it
that seriously
yeah yeah i don't know it just
i don't know that always like my dad's
head yankees man you can't reason with
them they always want you to pay for
something they want you to pay for
parking or they want you to pay for some
kind of license
[ __ ] that i just do it yeah that's my
dad
they're trying to get money out of you
know that that's my dad
basic oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
but my grandmother was like that they if
you were if you were northern you were
inhuman
you know just yeah which like i said
that's you know it's
[ __ ] weird yeah it is weird and i
thought it was weird when i was a kid
you know what i mean even back then i
was just kind of like what the
it was just different you guys are old
[Laughter]
yeah
like i said it's i i distinctly remember
even when i was a kid
being like i never want to be i mean you
know i knew that i was going to be an
old person
like physically but i was just kind of
like i don't want to ever mentally be
like
the old people that i had seen around
so a lot of times if i you know make
jokes about lego [ __ ] old people or
whatever that doesn't necessarily have
to do with how old you actually are
you could be a 25 year old old person it
depends on what your [ __ ] attitudes
are
you know what i mean i've met some
people younger than me that i
still considered old people just because
of the way they
like acted and the way they thought and
stuff because they just seemed like old
people to me
jamie said pennsylvania must be southern
because i grew up with pecan pie and
sweet potato pie
actually the thing is everybody says
that pennsylvania outside
of uh you know philadelphia and
pittsburgh is kind of like
rednecky that's what i've always i've
been to philadelphia once
like a long time ago but i haven't been
in any other place in
philadelphia though i think a lot of
that southern food
um like you said the desserts were kind
of universal
pecan pie apple pie um
sweet potato pie just depending on what
you had
if you look at southern like iconography
and you go back
into the 1800s and read the newspapers
and see how americans talked about each
other
southerners everything was white
southerners were basically descendants
of the british empire
but ethnically they were
irish and german most of them had
adopted english names though
to to try to get anonymity i guess would
be a good way to put it yeah you didn't
want anybody saying are you
like [ __ ] yeah you had to fit in not
a super super white person
yeah because the irish weren't really
considered to be white they were white
but they were like the garbage which is
so
funny because i mean people don't think
about it now because obviously irish
people are like white as [ __ ] but um
generally yeah but um yeah back in the
day irish people italians anything like
and people that
you know now any american would be like
yeah they're white people
yeah but back then not no well
you go back to this dumb you go back
into the honky motherland
on the island of the [ __ ] of the of
the main honkies or the secondary
honkies of the british okay
the irish for connie it's kind of the
slaves of the english
there's a bunch of genocides and they
[ __ ] just capture women
this is going back to like the eleven
hundreds and twelve hundred thirteen
hundreds fourteen hundred
centuries you know they just treated
them like garbage yeah
um the north was
so the south was kind of celtic and
tectonic you could see it in the flags
the [ __ ] flag of florida is the
[ __ ] northern irish flag basically
it's a white flag with a red x in it
it's just that ours has a disc on it
with some with some french look at this
[ __ ]
what we got [ __ ] oh is it going can
you guys hear me my [ __ ] came back again
it's been kind of going off and on
what's the stream quality say
no well i don't know i can't look at it
it's doing its thing
yeah i'm just like letting it roll
because
if you look at if the florida flag it's
this it's the flag of northern ireland
with a [ __ ] disc on it where the
indian woman looking out to the sea and
there's a ship coming and there's all
this [ __ ] fruit and vegetables at her
feet
i think it's an indian woman i i it is
yeah
and then you look at you know uh
confederate battle flags they kind of
look like
irish versions of the communion jack you
know
the the north was more anglo
there were a lot more english and
scandinavians you know
there's a lot of people that were from
sweden
and denmark and stuff from up there you
know
so back in those days there was
a big ethnic qua a big ethnic um
component it was
white boy blood feuds going back
centuries
as part of it going back to the honky
motherland they were mad at each other
well that's the thing it's just kind of
like look i'm even the same race as you
but i'm still going to find some other
[ __ ] like to [ __ ]
argue about right which is sad
[Laughter]
well they all had a history of [ __ ]
with each other and went
about centuries and they didn't forgive
each other well like i said
even when i was in the uk in the 90s and
the 2000s
like the early 2000s it was just kind of
like man the english and the welsh
didn't like each other the english and
the scots didn't like each other nobody
liked each other yeah you know what i
mean
might be better now i'm not really sure
but you know modern southern white
people are
kind of just in general they're
basically irish people
basically some of them mixed in with
native american and some of them
slightly yeah that's what my heritage is
and some of them
slightly africanized too yeah and then
southern black people are are irish eyes
a lot of them if you if you actually do
a dna test on them a lot of them have
like a lot of irish blood in them
and they don't know a lot or they don't
seem to know i've seen videos
these black girls from the south get dna
test
and uh you know they're got this [ __ ]
fantasy that they're going straight back
to wakanda
well i think the test results come back
and they're like
50 [ __ ] european and it's ireland
well that's the thing i feel like a lot
of people
you know unless your family didn't move
around much yeah you mixed most people
are some kind of months i mean my gran i
certainly am my granddad on my mother's
side
was part syrian of all things he was a
syrian christian or his mother was a
syrian christian
and you know just just the way it was
you know
yeah i actually was like from virginia
yeah i did uh
i did that dna thing like on the my
maternal side
and going back we're pretty much uh
middle eastern
yeah so you know well a lot of the
founding fathers had middle eastern
blood a lot of people don't
realize that looking thomas jefferson
was [ __ ] part syrian
yeah it was because all that stuff goes
back to the ottoman empires and you know
the england the roman empire broke into
two and the eastern roman empire was
became very uh middle easternized in a
ways
you know there was always been crossover
even going back to the motherland yeah
like i said everybody's just
and the gauls where the ancient french
may have had
some middle eastern ancestry and
evidently the celts who were the irish
may have come from the middle east
it's just that you know the map was
different back then and not everybody
was where you expected them to be
oh i didn't expect them to be there
didn't expect ambition
what are you doing here yeah it is
that's why i was in when i was living in
egypt man i'd run into dudes that had
[ __ ] red hair
a ginger an arab did you have a soul
i don't know but he's a ginger
yeah now you know a lot of white people
got taken as slaves
during uh you know the um
during certain parts of the muslim era
of the what do you call them the uh
the crusades yeah but then also some
europeans just
moved there and stayed during the
crusades period
yeah you know some knights said [ __ ] it
i i'm not going back to europe i'm gonna
stay right here
that happened also some nights converted
to islam
there's a bunch of stuff that happened
that people don't realize but see that's
why i find history so fascinating
because
it's always like way more complicated
than we give it credit for
you know jenny green is my favorite
color is it yeah he's got all those damn
eyes i like the blue one better the
green looks pretty good well i was just
like i said i got a purple one i got a
blue one i got a red one i got this and
i was like
what the [ __ ] man it's coming back
everybody get off the internet everybody
looking at porn knock it off
[Laughter]
it's still it's still uh loading on
their side oh [ __ ]
well let's see maybe it'll come back and
it's no sound either huh
i don't see how that could be
just tell me i don't know if i need to
[ __ ]
restart it
about to hulk out
okay i got the green hair already it's
like you know i'm almost there
hulking out this is why i drink you guys
it's bad they're saying it's back it's
back yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] it
what it was why
i drink well among the many other
reasons that i drink but you know
this is a big reason why we just kept we
just kept the uh
we just kept the stream open and it
eventually reconnected well
sometimes i think that the mistake that
i made before was that as soon as it
froze up i was like [ __ ] this and i was
kind of like but if you sometimes if you
leave it
and you just keep on talking yeah then
sometimes it comes back
yeah you know what i mean it's almost
kind of like there's an interruption in
the stream
yeah see there's a disturbance in the
forest don't make me touch anything
no it's free it's frozen it's frozen
it's frozen it hasn't frozen over here
i know but i'm just saying if you touch
that it'll [ __ ] it up just don't
you're worried don't touch anything i'm
trying not to
touching the mouse will not cause it to
do you know what you were the one that
told me not to touch the mountain yeah
a couple weeks ago do you not remember
that in the house i'm gonna touch the
mouse let's see if it locks up
[Laughter]
yeah look look look the image froze from
there
so you told you i told you i can't
understand i told you there's got to be
something
[ __ ] wrong with that i told you not
to touch anything what i might have to
do is i might have to adjust
the settings and go to like a lower
lower resolution resolution but it's
like i can't do that right now because i
don't remember how to do it
but um you know i might have to do it
for the next one for the friday show but
you know what i mean
it's got to be a way i mean well there
is but i can't do it right now
please don't stress me out like that you
know what i mean
look they're they're laughing when i
said i'm gonna touch it and he touched
it in the second they're going listen to
jenny tom listen to janet
he never does he never does damn it
he doesn't always he's a dude they don't
listen to anybody but at least so
little memory that moving the mouse
is enough to get it to [ __ ] up
well honestly this seriously this
computer
the with the weird [ __ ] that it does
with the microphone it's like i'm
honestly just like afraid to like
move anything i'm afraid to like touch
anything i'm afraid to like
move my chair i'm getting rid of that
piece of [ __ ] we're gonna get you
another
that wasn't the one we wanted anyway
everything else was sold out that was
just a random one we had to get yeah i
went to like
target or target yeah we had to get a
laptop and all
of them were [ __ ] sold out yeah there
was like two left and it's like this was
the
the more expensive one and i just got
this one that wasn't the more expensive
one
that was the cheaper one the better one
the better one was at
um best buy best buy and they were sold
out
oh that's right the one i wanted was the
best buy and it was sold out so then i
went to target
went to target and they had they had
like two
yeah they had better ones that were sold
out and this is the only thing that was
there
everybody decided they needed a laptop
at the same time as i decided i needed
one
and this was kind of like the budget one
and i was kind of like well i kind of
need one because my other [ __ ] was broke
and i was like well
and i said well it's only for streaming
and how much [ __ ] how much does it
actually need it was a 300
laptop though it wasn't like it wasn't
like it was free
you know it could have been free if we
had to run really fast
a [ __ ] phone can do better than this
well yeah that's what i'm saying maybe
we should just see because i just bought
a new phone maybe we should just use it
i'm just going to use the phone yeah
seriously though see we moved too much
it stopped again
he did yeah well i don't know i don't
know
okay just see what happens just don't
move around too much don't move around
too much
all right so i think i said on the thing
so we started watching like last night i
was watching a couple movies right
come on come on come on come on i was
watching a couple movies and then i was
like really tired and i was like
what the [ __ ] else what can i watch so i
don't have to really like concentrate
too much on
and i remembered that netflix
had added season 11
of hoarders and for whatever reason
i'm not super into like reality tv or
any of this kind of like hey
look at these trashy ass people
kind of shows but i don't know
for some reason i'm fascinated by
hoarders maybe because my grandfather
was a hoarder
so it's kind of like so i can like
relate
and the thing about the people that are
on hoarders every single episode that we
watch and [ __ ] man the like the new ones
the season 11 ones
they're like an hour and a half they're
like a movie length man and they only
like talk about cause remember back in
the old days
when they did hoarders it was always
they'd had like um two different orders
and then they would go back and forth
like between the two and the show was
only like an hour long or something
oh thanks well the new ones only
concentrate on one person
and the [ __ ] is like an hour and a half
long right so i was just kind of like
holy crap
so they get like way more into like in
depth about what the [ __ ] these people's
problem is i mean they all have the same
problem
they're hoarders right which you know is
a disorder
but for whatever reason people that have
that particular mental illness
just frustrate me so much and i really
like the one we just watched like the
first one and the woman's name
was carol right and
she was basically
the worst i mean i don't know they're
they all kind of suck
but she's um she was the worst what
ended up happening
there was this beautiful they had a
beautiful house it was in missouri i
think
it was like a three story it was a
mansion for real um you know it was old
i think it was built in like 1905 or
something like that
but it was a gorgeous gorgeous house
like one of those old like old-style
like colonial-looking houses beautiful
so i guess that had been owned by her
husband date or her husband dave his
name was dave yeah
now dave had been married before to this
woman named b
and she had committed suicide she had
hanged herself
in the [ __ ] basement of this house
right so
that was kind of a thing and after she
died
um the couple had been friends with this
woman carol
18 months after b committed suicide
carol
like and dave got married right
which seemed a little weird
okay but you know whatever not judging
this is back in the 50s or 60s or
whenever it was
and um maybe 70s i can't remember but
so they got married and
not only did carol start spending
a whole bunch of money by
running up debts on the dead wife's
credit cards
but also started filling this gorgeous
gorgeous house
up with crap right because she was one
of those ones that
oh i have to go to a thrift store and
have to buy like all these million
things like baskets and clothes and all
that other kind of crap
so this house which is three stories it
was like [ __ ] huge and it was just
like packed with
[ __ ] and this woman was just
i mean her husband was like an old man
and he was like on oxygen and stuff and
he was just kind of like in one
he lived in like the living room like on
the couch
oh i thought you were doing that already
i had no restrooms no
oh what was spooky doing
who keeps asking for [ __ ] so yeah so
this so the sick ass dude whose house it
is
right because this is him and his you
know
passed away wife had bought this house
like a long time ago
and then this woman
came in and like married him later and
then filled his house up with crap and
also put him like 400 500 000
in debt so awesome and this woman was
just so
[ __ ] i don't understand like they
have
um you know the same people they have
that one like super
annoyingly perky woman on the show that
is kind of like the hoarding expert and
she's the one that like leads up all the
crews like the cleanup and stuff
and uh you know like i said she's really
perky which kind of gives me a migraine
but um
you know they i don't understand how
people have patience
to deal with people with that disorder
because i don't know man they just kind
of [ __ ]
they got this woman out there and they
put i think they ended up taking like 32
tons of [ __ ] out of this house right and
it's like
man it was like [ __ ] dumpsters and
dumpsters well
and she was just like sitting on the
couch and it's like every time they
would bring something out it was like a
box it was literally full of garbage
like there was mouse poop all over
everything and it's like no
we can't throw this away i need this
piece of paper i need this stuff
what the [ __ ] man it's like and i don't
know i don't know how
like you know psychiatrists or whoever
like you know therapists that have to
deal with people with this disorder i
don't
understand how they can just like not
pop them in the face and just be like
look we're just throwing all your [ __ ]
away or
we're just going to burn your house down
and see the ground with salt because
i just i don't know i i don't have the
patience for that i don't have a fairly
patient per well i don't know if that's
true but it's like i'm a fairly
patient person but it's like i don't i
don't know i don't think i could deal
with somebody that was just kind of like
oh it's i need that garbage i need that
you know what i mean
i don't get it but yeah so this woman
was terrible
and then they got the house cleaned up
amazingly
and it looked awesome like i said it was
a gorgeous house
and everything seemed to be awesome like
you know all the family was getting
along they were having this big [ __ ]
kumbaya moment
and then they have that little uh after
thing where they tell you what happens
like after the
you know crew left or whatever they're
like uh yeah well
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] uh decided
that she was like [ __ ] this house i'm
not because oh because there was like a
lien on it too because she hadn't paid
the bills
right because she spent all the money uh
buying a bunch of crap
and so she was like [ __ ] this place i'm
gonna go move into this apartment with
my son
where she had been living so she left
left the sick ass
her sick ass husband there he died later
on like after the [ __ ] show was over
and then she was like you know not my
problem bye and then she took off
and then her and the family never talked
to each other again she wouldn't go to
therapy and she was just being
like [ __ ] all y'all i was like that's
nice i don't understand
i don't i don't know how people can deal
with people like that i just really
don't
you know yeah and honestly
yeah and man
it's just it's a fascinating show but
for some reason it's like i really
really want to watch it but then like
every time i watch it i'm just kind of
like oh my god i just want to punch this
person in the throat
i watch hoarders and then when i get
done with that [ __ ] makes you want to
clean the [ __ ] house
yeah i'm like man i got today you you're
like i'm going to clean out the laundry
room
yeah yeah that was [ __ ] funny
yeah he cleaned up all the like but he
cleaned out the laundry room like are
you working
everything reorganized everything like
by the coffee station like
he cleaned everything up yeah i can't
stand it but that well that's kind of
like what's good about watching it is
that it makes you want to clean stuff up
yeah yeah you clean like all the
bathroom floors and everything people
talking about your views i have to admit
i love shoes
she likes handbags and cosmetics she
gotta stop yeah
yeah yeah i know i love shoes too
he also loves i also love shoes i love
women's shoes i've been vividly
i mean i like shoes like if i see a nice
pair i'm like ooh but i'm not like one
of those people that's kind of like
oh my god shoes i'm not one of those
yeah she said what makes you want to
disinfect everything it does
it does those people are [ __ ] so
nasty my skin starts [ __ ] crawling
and i'm like going
imagine smell imagine the smell in that
place i mean and this one
this one was i mean it was gross because
anytime you pile up as i said
31 tons of stuff 31 tons they took out
of that house
and then they find [ __ ] like dead cats
yeah this one they found some dead rats
they were like mummified
dead dog in the damn house yeah [ __ ]
look at this this [ __ ] fr
look it [ __ ] froze up on yours it
didn't freeze here though well as long
as it's not freezing on yours that i'm
just gonna keep on [ __ ] going go
through it [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah seriously
i'm just over it
yeah but um but yeah so this one wasn't
too bad in the sense that this wasn't
like the bag [ __ ]
you remember the bag and yeah woman was
[ __ ] in the bag
and they just throw it in the bathtub
and then she had
a pile of plastic bags with
poop in them and then she filled up the
whole bathtub and the ceiling and then
she started throwing it around the
window
yeah in this store and she had a whole
bathroom
filled with bags full of [ __ ] and the
floor collapsed and it ate through the
damn floor
yeah and that just reminded me of
something yeah you
plastic will not stop those that
bacteria and
my friend my friend just sent me a
[ __ ]
a clip from somebody took from a cell
phone this is how stupid people are
at the gas station chinese lady jumps
out of her car
takes a plastic bag puts the gas nozzle
in it and
fills up the plastic bag full of
gasoline
ties it sets it down that's not gonna go
the way she thinks okay
and she goes gets another plastic bag
picks it up puts that bag in the other
one
as it's she picks it up gasoline starts
coming out of course this eats right
through that [ __ ]
and then she takes it puts that in the
other double bag she double bagged it
and guess what she did she put it in the
[ __ ] trunk and
shut the trunk and drove away wouldn't
have been
it would have been kind of funny it's
like no one ended the video she saw her
driving away
that was a big yeah because it eats
right through that [ __ ] plastic and
it's right her trunk is filled with
gasoline
and the dude the dude who's taking the
phone is going what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] does she think she's doing
no she's not doing that and a guy in the
back
i don't know where i don't know where
this gas station is but pretty much
every gas station it has a convenience
store
sells those little five gallon gas cans
yeah well she wanted to save money i
mean i bought them
remember mad tv swan the korean legend
yeah the woman who
pretended to be a korean woman called
swan that's what it looked like was
feeling that the swan
miss swan yeah
i never looked like a man but you are
you look like you look like a man i see
you pookie i see your little shadow
coming in
i saw your shadow on spock's crotch yeah
in the background
can we talk about since you're talking
about videos can we please talk about
that video you showed me last night
about that little irish girl
oh yeah who i can show it here if you
want
there's a little irish girl she's six
yeah with little cheeks painted red she
does not understand
why she's not allowed to go to the pub
she tried what poke no poop
she's trying to get in the closet she's
like well i wanna come in and pull it
out
so [ __ ] hey you guys suck
you guys this little six-year-old girl
uses reason like a [ __ ] and
logic like a [ __ ]
trying to reason herself into the pub
and your mom's going like you can't go
to the pub
you're just little you're just little
and she's like i'm sick she tries
she tries to reason that six is old
enough to go and then she's saying well
i went that one time this is because
that was for your father's birthday
and then she starts pulling out all
these other friends of hers
that we're allowed to go over a lot of
times she wants to go to the pub to see
her dad and her dad's friends [ __ ]
drink a beer
and she's just very she keeps saying i'm
six yeah
i'm sorry i'm six like because my own
mother would not let me go to the pool
i said mother my own mother would not
let me go to that little girl was
awesome
yeah and it's like inexplicably yeah she
had like little
like red circles painted on her cheeks
yeah for whatever reason i don't really
know why
but it was just really funny like her
little gestures and like all the [ __ ]
that she was saying
my own mother will not let me go yeah my
own mother won't let me she said mutter
and you want to be irish
[Laughter]
why didn't i go to the phone yeah she
keeps going like that
it's so [ __ ] funny oh my god
he was showing me to that last night and
i was just [ __ ] dying yeah
but yeah let me show you too i mean you
know i can
i can pull that up my own motor
she reasons the [ __ ] out of this
yeah hand yeah handbags and cosmetics
i have a lot of cosmetics because i have
a um
what's that thing that subscription
service ipsy
and every month they send you that
little cosmetics bag with like five or
six little like samples of [ __ ] in there
so um some of that stuff i use
some of it not so much and i'm just kind
of like oh well i'll just like keep this
over here and i'll you know give them to
somebody that can use them and like that
never happens
you know what i mean i gotta get this
commercial and i'll show it
all right so it's like i don't i don't
think i'd call it a horn but
i do have it in like a big cookie tin
[Laughter]
here she is okay her own mother will not
let her go
to the pub
okay you got me there
this many yeah
um
for her daddy's birthday party
i rest my case
nope
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh
um
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
just trying to use reason like crazy and
it's just not working
this reason doesn't work whether with
other irish people
well i can understand because like when
you're a little kid
when you're a little kid you have your
own uh
agenda and you have your own little
logic which like i said it's a little
kid logic but okay
but it can be very frustrating when
something
uh makes complete and total sense to you
and yet it seems like it doesn't make
any sense to the adults
and you're trying to tell them i mean
like i said i'm sure it does seem very
unfair to her
that maybe her little friends got to go
to the pub for like parties and stuff
and they're not letting her go
so you know i can understand what it
stop it with the focus yeah my own
mother yeah
tina noticed it she's a future attorney
that's what
he said yeah yeah that's what i mean
very much that kid should be able to
very much so
seriously very much and i love i loved
the eyebrow
action that she had where she was just
where she did that little like pity me
kind of
eyebrow at that point she was just kind
of like but
she was like that it was like very
important she's gonna do the whole thing
please you have to understand
oh that's so [ __ ] funny uh let's see
wednesday is my late night i blame these
two
sorry yeah three i mean you know we
don't think about it
it's not late for us it's only like five
it's only 6 20. i mean it's still
daylight out here for christ's sake
which is crazy because
you know i changed because we're
drinking already changed my drink out to
pineapple upside down cake
[ __ ] are [ __ ] missing out we
actually do you know what
an apple upside it tastes tasty it
tastes just like i know
that it's all right we actually kind of
he's like here taste this thing you've
tasted in a million times
yeah um we also got he was at the
he was at sam's the other day and he
came home with uh beer
he had some was it yeah guinness stout
and you got that apple orchard like that
angry orchard or a apple so we could
make snake bites
yeah you pour half and half which like i
said i'm not a big beer fan but snake
bites are good yeah
with the apple cider apple cider with
[ __ ] stout it's good
real good yeah we were we were drinking
that the other night while we were
watching uh
piranha which is what we the review for
this week there was this bar we used to
go to what's that club where they used
to play the [ __ ] cold wave of music
the falcon falcon yeah it's still there
yeah we got to go to the falcon again
i'm like about time to go to the photo
that's their friday nights it's friday
nights they do their show yeah they had
a good dj's he's still playing down
there
probably at home okay and go down there
because uh yeah nick
yeah instead of instead of um they
didn't have apple cider
they didn't have hard cider there they
had pear
cider yeah and i was putting that in
guinness stout and that was good too
that was also very good they were
looking like i was crazy and i was going
like no man we just do this in boston
this is some [ __ ] hardcore mix [ __ ]
right here man [ __ ] you put that put
that in there they drink it
there's all kinds of different drinks
that those guys they're irish americans
you know but [ __ ]
whitey bulger and all those guys up
there
whitney bulger i told that story already
he just died recently
yeah i just lived in this winter hill so
i was
i remember them i remember him because
he
is one he was one of the suspects for
that um
murder that happened up there uh what
was it called like the lady of the dunes
or whatever
who i don't think i still don't think
they've ever identified no but he was
one of the suspects that i'm saying i
don't know if he did it or not
um but yeah somebody was saying tila was
saying we were talking about uh
the pooh porter um did she think she was
saving it like for fertilizer
i'm not you know what and that kind of
occurs to me because it's like man i'm
gonna watch some more hoarders tonight
and i'm gonna be really drunk and be
yelling at the people
because that's what i do yeah but um
like i said this one wasn't gross gross
they did find some mummified rats and
[ __ ] like once they got everything out
of the house
but it wasn't like a poop order
situation and some of the
ceiling was falling in but it wasn't
kind of like they were gonna condemn the
house i have to say so i don't know if
they actually ended up tearing it down
because they didn't
like pay all the bills like i said it
kind of went sideways
after but i don't know
because this house didn't have running
water either
and i don't so you could use the toilet
but you had to like take a bucket of
water in there
see i don't understand like once it gets
to the point where there's so much crap
in your bathroom for christ's sake that
you can't even use the toilet without
taking a bucket of what
it's like why would you want to impose
like life is already enough
of a pain in the ass it's like why would
you want to make it even
more arduous those people are [ __ ]
insane jenny yeah
i know and it's like i get it i get it
it's a mental illness i get it and it
doesn't make any sense but it's like
i mean it does but not from my point of
view like i said my grandfather was a
hoarder so i get it
but it's kind of like i just i find that
probably the most frustrating mental
illness because
you can see why they developed these
particular
proclivities that they have but you
can't like talk them out of it
no they want to keep like every [ __ ]
old you know [ __ ] mcdonald's cup
yeah i could understand they just want
to keep it i can understand it if you're
in fear of
poverty or loss yeah i get that and some
of them are
you might want to try to save things
that maybe will help you later
yeah or things that you feel like might
be and there's also something
too about they're taking that [ __ ] to a
[ __ ] yeah it's it's kind of like okay
i get like i said if you go like a lot
of people that grew up during the
depression for example
like later on they tended to hoard food
or they would save things or they would
pick things out of the garbage i get
that because
that's from their point of view that's a
very practical hey i could use this i
could repurpose this
you know and sometimes they did and
that's cool so it's kind of like it's a
natural human
thing and up to a point it's probably
good it's probably good to reuse things
but they just take it to an extreme
where you know like i said this woman
she's pawing through a box full of
papers that had mouth [ __ ] all over them
furniture had mouth [ __ ] all over it and
she wants to keep the [ __ ] and she wants
to keep it without cleaning it
but the thing is is that one wasn't that
bad she was bad but she wasn't as bad as
some of the other no
i mean her would live remember that
woman that lived in the pile of filth
yeah she would actually piss and [ __ ] in
the pile of filth yeah
and there was rats and cats trying to
live in there with her
and it was just place was [ __ ]
terrible and they had that other woman
who was
she was a hoarder she had a [ __ ] ton of
cats and couldn't throw away dead cats
she put dead cats in the refrigerator
yeah they were like in the freezer oh
man
no they were in there that refrigerator
and all the damn cat juice had fallen to
the bottom remember that
[ __ ] no man no that woman was very
mentally ill
and uh some of these hoarders
are not fit for society i kind of feel
like they really need to be
in a structured environment they have to
be in an
outpatient or an inpatient type
situation
where they're in like a minimum security
facility they can't live on their own
they have to be in a dorm with a cot or
a bunk
and you gotta you can't give them
anything because they'll just hoard
yeah you know they can't and i feel like
there's a really pretty high like res
you know i don't know the percentage but
i feel like there's a really high like
recidivism rate for this because
that's why they try to do like even on
the hoarder show they try to do like
after the show ends after they clean all
your [ __ ] out
yeah they try to do uh aftercare like
after
because the reason i know it's
frustrating for me to watch but it's
always kind of like
you know i'm usually with the family
members that are like hey can we just
like bulldoze all this [ __ ] out of here
just burn the house down and start over
because that just seems like the easiest
thing to do because like obviously none
of this crap
i mean all this crap is garbage why do
we need it but
i understand that the therapists are
trying to
cure the people by trying to make them
realize
this [ __ ] does is garbage you don't need
it
why do you need to hang on to it you
know it's like why don't you
because a lot of them i feel like
they're they hoard stuff
because they don't have um or for
whatever reason they feel like their
relationships are not like you know
their family
a lot of times it happens like after you
know their parents die
or you know this their sibling dies or
so they have like a
tragedy in the family and so they feel
like stuff is the only thing they can
hold on to because it's like i
won't leave them um so i get that
but it just gets to a point where they
get so entrenched
that some of them i don't know if they
can be helped
you know no i don't think so some are
irreversible david june says cat juice i
don't know if i want to laugh or puke
yeah that was oh that was such a yeah
the woman that was hosting it when
when she opened up that refrigerator she
[ __ ] went back
she screamed because it was a it was a
deadly
dead cat on the [ __ ] um
refrigerator shelf and underneath it
a couple racks down was like about an
inch of black
juice cat juice she'd been keeping
dead cats in the refrigerator and
[ __ ] she jumped out of her skin when
she saw that [ __ ] it was [ __ ] macabre
very macabre i mean and she was kind of
a harmless looking old lady that was
doing it she just if a cat would die she
couldn't get rid of it she'd put it in
the freezer
when she ran out of [ __ ] room she'd
put them in the refrigerator
but they're mentally ill well yeah hold
on
i want to talk to him um david uh
i don't know if you were on the stream
earlier
because i made that [ __ ] extra triple
extra large shirt for you i decided to
make a bigger pliskin
[ __ ] logo it looks good man it's like
it's like it's big
which is the big you know that's the
size of this it's for it's gonna i'm
gonna put it on
medium sized shirts too as an option but
it was mostly targeted towards uh
big shirts so if you ever want another
one when you're ready i'll make you
it'll look a lot better than that um i
like that shirt and that shirt's a good
seller i want to put that on like olive
grab
olive drab or shirt with looking
you know like a green od green shirt
maybe with all
with [ __ ] gray or red prints there's
a bunch of [ __ ] i could do
but the the other two that i was working
on today that [ __ ] failed
i got a tyrell corporation shirt that
jenny made up
it says tyrell more human than human and
it has the tyrell
corporation logo and japanese writing
on it because it looks really cool and
the other one was a 13 o'clock shirt
that's
styled after a ouija board you guys are
going to see them soon they'll be done i
got to redo them tomorrow
yeah we got to reshoot them yeah i had a
problem with it was
you didn't expose them long enough
either expose your time or dry time one
of the two
it's always you gotta it's like so
[ __ ] delicate man
yeah and it looked great except in like
one area
yeah you didn't expose it yeah yeah i
gotta expose them for several hours each
and [ __ ]
there's gonna be it's a new um it's a
new emulsion that i'm using it's blue
instead of green and i i think the
exposure times longer on it
yeah um but we'll see yeah no need for
me too says hoarding would make a little
sense if they had practical reasons for
the stuff they save
yeah that's what i mean it's in some
ways it's like up to a point
it's probably good like i said to save
some things or reuse things you know
that's a totally normal thing to do
but once you're getting to a point where
you have so much [ __ ]
that your water gets turned off you
don't have running water you don't
plumbing you don't have any of that kind
of [ __ ] anymore
and then you're [ __ ] in bags and
keeping that
too that's um
you've kind of gone all the way to crazy
town at that point
because there's really no justification
i mean i understand how it happens
okay it's it's just like everything it's
like a matter of degrees it's like your
frog and boiling water kind of [ __ ]
it's like i'm gonna save this um you
know i'm gonna save these jars
for example this is something that you
save you save like artichoke heart
jars yeah that you can drink out of a
drink at them yeah which
like i said that's normal you because
you use them yeah
so i can see like that proclivity to do
that
but taken many many times further than
that
and then once it gets to a certain point
because it happens very slowly happens
very slowly
all of a sudden you got the water bill
you forgot to pay it because it got
buried under stuff and then like your
you know your water got turned off and
then your toilet doesn't work anymore
and at this point you're too embarrassed
to tell anybody so it's like well i'm
just gonna [ __ ] in a bag
yeah uh uh [ __ ] bag lady actually got
they tore her bag lady [ __ ] bag i'm
gonna call her [ __ ] bag well
yeah her her house got torn down i think
it did get torn down
and rightfully so well the floors had
collapsed yes and her house got torn
remember they they they told her to
[ __ ] hit the road
she left [ __ ] mumbling kicking rocks
mumbling i think they put her in a
facility yeah that's what was either
well she became homeless they shoved
that [ __ ] on television she left
walking away mumbling and kicking rocks
get the [ __ ] out of here her whole
family get out of here
so she just they just left her [ __ ]
homeless um
no need for me too if you want a shirt i
don't know what size you want
uh but you can drop a chat right here a
super chat
and that'll pay for the shirt and then
uh you can contact jenny oh he's a
patron too
oh he's a patron he's a patriot you can
contact us through patreon i'll hook you
up
i'm going to send out another because i
sent out a message on patreon for all
the 20
plus people that are going to get a
shirt um
but i'll send out another one before we
actually finish the shirts yeah there's
just to make sure
that everybody wanted a shirt i'm doing
all this because we're going to do a
patreon mail out for shirts
of people who so some patrons if they're
20
and up are going to get a shirt if
they've responded yeah they're going to
get a shirt of their choice
and yeah because i have three different
ones and i haven't got to know your size
and what you want because for all i know
and mailing address because
i've had some problems because some
people sign up for
patreon and then they're on there and it
just kind of like goes
without them like and so sometimes the
addresses have changed
we had that happen with one patron who
had moved a couple times
and then several months later we got the
shirt back
and then so i had to like contact her
and be like hey where do you live now
it's like i just got this shirt back
like two months later
you know what i mean because they said
it was undeliverable so i ended up like
sending it back out all right
extra large 13 o'clock you'll send the
address after okay okay that's good
yeah just send all the info yeah
wherever instagram facebook wherever
if you wait if you wait a bit i'm gonna
have a choice on 13 o'clock shirts
because i got that new one back there
yeah like i said we have two different
13 o'clock ones one looks like a ouija
board one that looks kind of like a
you know like decorative like clock kind
of thing and then we have a big plisk in
one
and then we have the tyrell one yeah
we probably so how much of the what are
the old um what are the old designs that
we have
got the one with me and you on it it's
13 o'clock okay we still got that i got
the small piston
i got uh wayland yutani i got wayland
i got um
there's got to be another one we got the
one with the uh grim reaper on it right
grim reaper yeah yeah yeah you've got
memories
yeah yeah yeah and the thing is
there's a couple more i want to do an
infantry type shirt with the infantry
cross rifle so i'm going to do that in a
kind of a [ __ ] military
format for 13 o'clock um
uh and then like a paramilitary version
remember was telling you about that
yeah yeah and i also want to get a um i
want to get a
um 327 recon tiger force [ __ ] shirt
that'll be good
all right and then um but we'll worry
about all that later that
i think there's a couple more i want to
come up with we got time
yeah we're just you know i know
everything takes forever but yeah
everything takes forever because i
i essentially have three jobs right so
you know i get a round of [ __ ] but it
takes
longer than i uh think sometimes yeah
like i said it's just kind of like the
cookbook where it's just kind of like i
swear to god
all i have left to do on the [ __ ]
cookbook yeah
i have i think five more pictures of you
that i have to cut the uh backgrounds
out
and put them in and then i just have to
like redo the cover real quick it's done
it's just i have to like
[ __ ] do it with the newer photo and
then it'll be finished
yeah no need for me he's an army vet so
he he wants a
military okay yeah i'm gonna do a cool
infantry one it's gonna have a patriotic
theme
it'll have the 13 o'clock logo a [ __ ]
label in the back all the shirts that i
make have on the back so it says 13
o'clock yeah i made like a new little
like
logo thing with all the things yeah do
you know what i thought of today
as if i didn't already have like because
this is the thing i feel like
i feel like i'm busy and i'm stressed
out all the time but it's always kind of
like [ __ ] that we came up with and it's
like oh we should do this and then i'm
just kind of like oh my god now i have
like 40 million things to do
today i don't know why i thought of this
i was like you know what i should do
because you know
um if you guys have been watching uh you
know i do that flickers of fear thing
which is uh
you know where i review movies just so
like on my own i have this massive list
i was kind of like you know what i
should do like for halloween or for
october
i should do a movie review for every day
of october because i see like a lot of
horror channels
have done that like 31 days of halloween
and then i was kind of like oh well
maybe i should start now because then
i would have like 31 of them and i could
put them all up like one every day like
in october right
and then i was just kind of like why the
[ __ ] am i making so much more work for
myself but it's a cool idea though
i even made a list like earlier like all
the movies i wanted to do
i don't know maybe i'll do it yeah but i
i just kind of i know it's only april
but i was just
wait no may it's may i don't even know
what month it is
but um yeah i was just kind of like well
maybe i should start it now because then
by the time october comes then i'll
already have a month worth of stuff
that i could record ahead of time you
know yeah yeah no need for me i got a um
i'm going to have a couple of military
designs paramilitary
type design one of them's going to be a
um
one through one three two seven recon
tiger four shirt
i was in that unit so i have a right to
give it to you
i get to just to sell it and give it to
people as a gift of the show
and tiger force i was in tiger force art
history was classified up until recently
and they started to [ __ ] declassify
the history
of the vietnam theater the vietnam
theater
you can see that [ __ ] on on wikipedia
it's out of context now make you sound
really [ __ ] bad
but yeah we my unit [ __ ] was the
we were the ones that [ __ ]
trademarked all that ear taken
year taken and doing bad things to
people they were out
out guerrillaing guerrilla in the
gorillas
working with [ __ ] south vietnamese
forces and doing [ __ ]
no one was ever convicted of anything
and they were but they were accused of a
lot of stuff
it's not it's not stated there but they
were working for
um in that in those days my unit was
working for
uh well mag v sog and cia
was telling them to do stuff that's why
there were no convictions
they were just trying to out brutal it
was like
something straight out of apocalypse now
back in that theater
but it was a good unit there's only 40
of us
let me uh go to the rescue yeah i was
just going to ask you if i could go but
i guess
when i come back but yeah so
all right so what was i talking about
okay so i don't know i guess tonight
maybe
i might watch some more hoarders but
i don't know it makes me so mad it's
almost kind of like
the one that we watched the one that tom
was like talking about earlier with the
cats in the refrigerator
um i have like i can watch a lot of
gross [ __ ]
but that man
that just made me start gagging and i
couldn't stop gagging it's kind of like
if you guys ever watch because we've
talked about like dan bell
and he's kind of uh you know best on
youtube for
his dead maul videos but he also does a
series
called adr another dirty room and him
and his compatriots will go
and stay in like the grossest motel
rooms
in america and they do like a room
breakdown so they'll pull back all the
sheets they'll take all the
pillows out of the [ __ ] they have all
the [ __ ] they have luminol
they have the black lights they have
everything they have the
the thing that you like take swabs and
then stick it in the machine and it
tells you how much [ __ ] bacteria is
on there
and for some reason like i love that
show even though every single [ __ ]
time
every single episode of that show i
watch makes me want to throw up
i mean a couple of times i've watched
that and i was just kind of like
and i had to like run to the bathroom
and stuff especially the one he did he
did one
like a couple months back that was like
the 10 grossest
moments or whatever it was and it's like
i couldn't get through it
i watched like part of it and i'm just
like yeah i'm just gonna i'm barfing
forever
and it was just i mean
there was [ __ ] like this one hotel room
this one motel room they stayed in i
mean because they stay in some [ __ ]
crack dens right i mean and they've
actually found
um bags full of
you know [ __ ] hypodermic needles and
like [ __ ]
meth and [ __ ] like that they one time
they found a plastic bag full of like
used ladies underwear under a bed that
was nice
one of the grossest things i ever saw on
that [ __ ]
was somebody had opened
the drawer on the nightstand right
like where the gideon bible usually is
somebody had opened the drawer
and thrown up in it and then closed and
drawn
and nobody cleaned it for however long
so when they like opened the drawer
there's like just dry
like caked vomit like all over the
bottom of his eye which is like oh
no oh no i just couldn't
oh my god it was so nasty i mean
anything to do with like barf or like
when they go in the
in the [ __ ] bathroom and there's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] smears like on the [ __ ]
toilet seat or whatever
and also when they turn on the black
lights and then there's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
stains all over the wall
crap like what's the [ __ ] serious
[ __ ] going on what the [ __ ] is up with
like there was this
one well i don't even know if it's
hookers well it is but it's like
there was this one room they went in and
somebody
i don't know who do you know i don't
know if he was trying to like
do like do a [ __ ] um you know
guinness book of world records [ __ ] or
something
what's the matter pokey it's still light
out and it's hot you're not gonna like
it i'm telling you right now
she doesn't care and it's like she'll
scratch and scratch then we open the
door and then she sticks her head out
and she's like oh it's hot out and i'm
like yeah we told you
but then she forgets like 10 minutes
later she's like no i want to go outside
and then she's like oh [ __ ] this
but yeah so they so they did the [ __ ]
uh the black light like all over the
room it looked like
somebody had sat at the desk because you
know how in some motel rooms they have
that little kind of
table top that's like bolted to the wall
and they have like a chair
it looked like somebody had sat in that
chair
and jerked off underneath this desk
multiple times or multiple people had
done it
because they did the blacklight and
there's just [ __ ]
jizz all over the underside
he entertained everybody yeah and i was
just kind of like
oh my god and well the best thing about
the show
is that dan dan bell i love him yeah
and he just like i love whenever
something happens like that like in the
show he's like
oh my god and he just like gets [ __ ]
so
worked up about it it's so [ __ ] funny
so she takes me out to the [ __ ]
sliding door i knew that was to happen
i told you she goes up to the front so
she's like goes to the front door and i
open it up and she goes
nah and i went pookie what are you doing
outside
i'm walking away from her and she looks
at me like what you mad yeah
so she's over here trying to apologize
why is it hot outside why don't you fix
it
she wants us to turn it down turn it
down it's hot out there plus she thinks
back outside and front outside are two
different things i think these are
different outsides yes well because
what she'll do she'll be in the bedroom
because we have like a sliding glass
door in the bedroom right and she'll go
and she'll
she's like she'll scratch on the sliding
glass door
and then you open it she's like no no i
don't want to go out of the right i want
to go out the front door
she wants to sit on the front porch so
then she'll so she'll scratch like to
make noise until you
she gets her your attention and then
she's like no no and then she goes
and then she runs to the front door and
then you open the front door and then
she's like
nope i don't like that either i don't
like that either yeah well she thinks
that
she thinks it's going to be show her the
back door and she's like now it's too
hot
let's check the front yeah maybe it's
different you go to the front
outside out here well she's just
checking yeah she's just checking might
be
different outside it might be a
different outside well like i said
when we first moved in this house i
think every single door beijing
thought it was a different outside yeah
she had to go out every [ __ ] door
that led up she had a check
and she was like well no i don't like
this either
yeah and then like if you let her out
because beijing is like big and fluffy
yeah and we i mean we lived here for a
few years before we got pookie so we had
beijing first
and she so she would go outside like
reluctantly and then she'd look back at
us like
what did you guys do yeah why did you
[ __ ] this up why is it so hot outside
she would be like that yeah she blamed
me for the temperature
she did yeah look she'd look at me like
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah why did
you do it
she turned it down she thinks you did it
yeah
that's what's so funny and it's funny
because
too because i was on my uh hike this
morning she doing poo
she's like i don't know i'm just you
gonna beat up baby yoda
yeah she hasn't bothered baby yoda since
that one time when she just like jumped
and like
[ __ ] knocked him off the ground if
you guys remember that that was pretty
epic
but yeah so i was out of my hike this
morning and i saw
uh mr mcguire formerly known as pap
kitty
and he uh they told me
like because i know i don't you know i
don't know no but i know people that
like
you know jog or walk their dogs or
whatever like because i see the same
people every morning
so this guy that always walks like his
wife feeds the cat too but she comes out
earlier than me
so she told she said that
uh mr mcguire had got a rat this morning
because what happened with what happens
with mr mcguire he's like real fluffy
right and he's a barn cat so he lives
outside
on his sides like his hair's all matted
and today like because i keep saying man
i really need to
bring some scissors so i can like get
this off of here but it looks like
somebody did that
because on one side of him there's still
like a little bit of a mat but it looks
like somebody tried like had cut off one
side of the mat
but the other side of the mat there's
like this big hunk of fur and
i don't know if he did it or if somebody
else did it but the fur
is kind of like the mat is kind of like
pulled away
so you can see his skin it's like down
to the skin
you know what i mean and then this
morning there was like a little bit of
blood on there
so i don't know if he pulled it off or
if the rat pulled it off because like
the lady said that
he'd been fighting he'd caught a rat
that morning
i don't really know pookie's her
nickname i'm talking to people in there
uh t is asking how we name these guys
okay i named the cats
well the first cat beijing i named
at that time this was a long time ago
now yeah this was before i met you even
yeah cause you had her when i
yeah started going out with you i was
working at the barn as a handler at that
time
and one of the students was a high
school girl
named candace we called her candy little
candy
i knew her mom big candy all right
little candy little candy big
[Laughter]
big candy was visago's attorney
defense attorney what's his name oh the
vampire the vampire killer
yeah yeah yeah ron farrell rod feller
rod farrell
so it was rod farrell's mom's
rob farrell's no rod farrell's
attorney's there you go came up to me
and goes
tom katie's in england now she's a
professional [ __ ]
english equestrian rides other people's
horses real expensive
[ __ ] okay tom they're gonna
kill it and i was like what take it
they're gonna kill it and i said what
are you talking about
she had this little kitten in her hands
and she's going
if nobody adopts the cat that they're
gonna
kill it and it was she got it out of
some house that
they were trying to get rid of all these
little kittens
and she gave it to me i said okay i said
give me that kid
well that's what i mean if anybody came
up to you they're gonna get i'm just
like
give them so i took the cat and it was
on the day
of the opening of the beijing olympics
yeah that's when that happened
so that name suits her though so i
called her beijing
yeah or you're gonna kill it we call her
beige or
or princess fluff ass that's what i call
her because she has this
like she's super fluffy and if you look
at her like walking
from the back like she has this massive
like fluffy
a woman had a brazilian woman
had pookie okay and sent me a uh
video she said that she should tell a
story
we don't know if the story should that
story's not true she's a brazilian
she said we found this kitten and she
was very
i mean pookie was very very small her
eyes were still blue
yeah um they she said i found her in the
backyard and there was like a dog was
chewing on her or something yeah dog bit
her tail off
better he gave me this [ __ ] sob story
and she sent me a video
of pookie pookie was like the size of a
[ __ ] baseball
and he showed it to me and i'm like oh
my god and pookie's in a bird cage
[ __ ] um playing with something
yeah and and i said okay i'll take it
i didn't i didn't pay it i didn't well
we had been thinking about getting the
kitten anyway
and she was keeping it in the garage it
had been there for her because she had
dogs and she's like i don't want the
dogs
she had some kind of [ __ ] crazy ass
name for it
like simba something or other meant
bravery you know
and oh that's right i forgot about
fighting the dogs and
and it was a [ __ ] you know a very
strong
little boy cat and that was a girl later
on i was like man the cat's a girl
and then yeah she told me that he was a
boy and i'm looking at the cat and
[ __ ] i classified the cat as a manx
and it's just like any other manx and
[ __ ] event says oh that cat never had
its [ __ ] tail cut off but
that's just the radio that's just the
way her tail is she looks stumpy
it's just a story and it's you know
brazilian brazilian girl is going to
tell you a story
they just are so for a long time we
thought oh my god this poor kitten like
she got a i mean she did get abandoned
by her mom um
but she was just found in the backyard
and there was like a dog chewing on her
dog chew her tail off and stuff and then
like later on and i was just kind of
like
wait a minute yeah i don't think she
ever had a tail
no she knew how to so and then so we got
the cat
and during that time i said man i'm
changing that name
and we had that cat in the bed with us
and the cat was looking like
looking at us like who are you people it
was funny when we first got her and she
started sleeping with us because she
would
she was in a garage in a bird cage i
mean she was little bitty thing
little so jenny uh was watching this
[ __ ]
youtube channel and it was called uh
what was it called
well it's beer and board game yeah beer
and board games and there's a character
on beer and board games it's just a
little baby doll
called um baby cookie baby cookie baby
cookie's
a little white baby from the hood yeah
and
who pops in okay she smokes she's a baby
and she smokes and she uh
she drinks she drinks and she has sex
and everything yeah
and she just says all kinds of funny
jokes and they did the little jokes of
baby cookie
so her real name is baby cookie but over
time
we started just calling her pookie well
the [ __ ] okay so
the thing about that is that we couldn't
decide
on a name for her for a really long time
because i was just kind of like
i want a name that like fits her because
beijing
her name fits her it's like it's a very
regal name and she's a very
regal kitty she's a rag doll and she's
like super fluffy
and so when we first got pookie i was
kind of like i'm
like we need to know her personality
like i want a name
that you know evokes her so for a long
time we couldn't think of anything
it's like i was kind of like and you
know the lady that gave her to us
like thought she was a boy and then we
only had her for maybe like a few days
and tom was like i'm pretty sure that's
a female cat
yeah and you know when we took her to
get fixed they were like yeah that's a
female it's like yeah that's what we
thought
because i don't know it was just like
she just struck
she struck us as a girl yeah so we kind
of went through a whole bunch of
different names um
the one i remember i remember we called
her otter pop for a while because
yeah the way her little tail stuck out
when she was little it was like this
little square
that stuck out of her butt and it kind
of looked like
um if you guys remember those [ __ ]
what are those
the like the otter pop things like those
ice yeah icy like
popsicle things and like that's what her
tail looked like
yeah so we called her that for a little
while and i'm like that's okay for now
but it's like
that's not really her name what
tila ebony supermodel has just sent us a
[ __ ]
super chat oh i'm behind us oh thank you
and pookie's mom tease furry babies
simon oh from t's
furry babies simon marley and leo [ __ ]
you can't read
i can read beijing and pookie from tea
teas furry babies yeah and so
we and so finally like we were kind of
like we were watching beer and board
games and they have that
that character on there who's a baby but
also kind of like a gangster
yeah so i was kind of like that seems
kind of like what she's like
because she's like a baby but she's like
she's kind of a tomboy
and she's kind of like a clown and she's
kind of tough yeah so
i was like that's kind of a good name so
we called her cookie for a little while
but then i started calling her pookie as
a
term of endearment like like her name is
baby cookie but she
is a pookie yeah like you know what i
mean and i kind of got that from
the old garfield comic because that was
the name of garfield's teddy bear
and she looks a little bit like a teddy
bear so i think that's why i thought of
it
but we we barely even call her
baby cookie anymore and now we just
she's just pookie poopster
pooka rama yeah super poopy pants
pooky pants yeah i mean just
thank you tila i mean did we just call
her like variations
one time we had been talking about h.p
lovecraft earlier in the day
and i accidentally called her pookatonic
university
yeah like it just came out before i
realized what i
said so you know that's that kind of
thing
what was that no [ __ ] you talked to her
in her little like stump go
back she looked at me when blake dries
no no her little stump goes back and
forth
are you blinking you can get out right
no she's good but yeah
it's like it's kind of like for a long
time like i said we thought that her
tail had been
bitten off of her or that she was
injured
yeah but the more we looked into it
i mean she has pretty much every single
personality if you look up a manx cat
every personality thing that they have
on meg's cat that's exactly
yeah yeah that's exactly what she's like
and she's
also another thing that like max cats
have they're very
small like in comparison she's a lot
smaller than beijing beijing is not as
big as she appears just because she's so
fluffy
but pookie is really
little for being she's almost four
your chat is so far behind i know that's
ridiculous
well that's i'm just not i'm not
touching anything i told you
okay because if you touch something
it'll [ __ ] something up
that's what i told you they're saying
i'm drunk but i'm not hat wearing drunk
no i got a hat on
i know it's like he brought the whole
like thing of hats in here and then he
forgot all about them
i guess like in the [ __ ] issue of all
the [ __ ] technical issues we're
having
you know i don't know i'm gonna get him
to wear one of my wigs one of these days
we'll see but yeah so we looked up like
the manx stuff and i was like oh my god
that sounds exactly
exactly like her and she's
like i said she'll be four she'll be
four this summer
and she is small
for a cat i mean she's pretty small
she's kind of like her body is like
normal size but she has like this little
round head and these little bitty short
legs you know what i mean which like i
said that's a very manx
uh thing and also she's real
um puppy-like
like she's always kind of she's not
aloof like beijing
is like your typical man [ __ ] you guys
she's very she's like paris hilton she's
like the paris hilton of cats
you know what i mean that's what we
always used to say she's just like a
princess she doesn't want to sit in your
lap she doesn't want
you to pet her it's like you can pet her
but she'll complain
um she just wants to like luxuriate on
her thing and go look how pretty
i am aren't i pretty she's like that
pookie is not like that pookie is like a
little
punk rocker you know what i mean
she's like this little bitty she has
these little stumpy legs this little
stumpy tail
this little round head and she is just
gonna like
she's like yeah she's like that she's
kind of like a little
[ __ ] she's a little fighter she kind
of like she wants to beat up on beijing
and it's like she's not
when we used to have that other cat that
lived here
that was uh tom's stepdad's cat garbo
and he was like a big black cat and he
was like really really old and he was
really overweight so at some point like
he couldn't really walk around that much
anymore
because he was so fat and he was kind of
sick and so he would just kind of lay
there and when we first got pookie
she just thought he she thought that
garbo was a ride at disneyland
because carbo would just be laying there
she'd be like whoo he's not gonna do
anything okay awesome and she would just
like jump on
it she would jump on his head she'd like
pull on his ears and
and garbo couldn't really do that much
about it he just kind of put up with it
he was just kind of like huh okay
at least somebody's playing with me it
was just that kind of it was that
he did go out she did okay i keep
going through the kitchen and i keep
passing by that big old pot of swedish
meatballs that i would well we can have
some out
god damn swedish meatballs sucking we're
good you gotta talk you talk about
pookie because i gotta i gotta go
you're gonna make you're gonna tell me
what i'm gonna talk about you could talk
about i gotta talk about pookie
i wanna talk about swedish meatballs man
okay okay well you've been to the
bathroom like three or four times
i haven't been one time because i'm a
man
yeah you have like because i'm a man we
don't
we don't need big bladders we can just
whip that [ __ ] out and just go wherever
we need to go you know
got a damn built-in dispenser system
you know y'all know what i'm talking
about
yeah i made some um i made some swedish
meatballs today
and what was funny is that i was
i had this big old thing a hamburger i
got from sam's
and i had to get it in the freezer but
it was too [ __ ] big
so i had to cut it into three pieces and
use at least one piece to make the
to make this big old pot of meatballs
you know so the rest of it you know i
could put it in bags and
get that in the freezer got to get that
[ __ ] frozen
you know especially with all this
[ __ ] weird ass
fuel problems with [ __ ]
pipelines and all this weird [ __ ] that's
going on
the coming [ __ ] civil war or whatever
this is
so i had to get that [ __ ] meat cooked
you know
so i made swedish meatballs
so i was kind of lying to myself i was
like
i gotta make these meatballs but i don't
want to go through all this [ __ ]
problem of [ __ ] soaking up bread and
making bread crumbs and [ __ ] using up
the [ __ ] bread that i got
i'm gonna use that can of just plain
bread crumbs i already have
so i dumbed this i dumbed this recipe
down just i just [ __ ] dumped it all
the way down
i just soaked breadcrumbs in [ __ ]
dry powdered milk you know neato and put
that in there with the seasoning and the
meat and [ __ ] churn it with the eggs
made a nice soft meatballs
dumbed it down didn't even i just put
them in pans and baked them
you said soft meatballs yes making them
you like them soft meatballs
as i dumbed everything down i was like
these are probably not gonna be that
good
what are you talking about they were
delicious and then i made the sauce
by the time the sauce was done those
meatballs were baked i baked them you're
never supposed to do they're supposed to
[ __ ] brown them in a pan
and it's just supposed to kind of like
bake them
in a pan full of [ __ ] sauce after
they're browned
[ __ ] that i i i dumbed all that down
i baked them just in [ __ ] glass pans
and then added them to the sauce
dumped and then the just really [ __ ]
simple
and then just let them simmer man it was
good got a lot of it's
really good the dumbed down version
of the swedish meatballs i think we're
better than the [ __ ]
than my normal more complicated version
sometimes simple is better
although i cannot believe how much
allspice we put in that
yeah it's still you notice that it still
was a
i mean it still was a little bit
unseasoned i think it was a lot of meat
it was yeah but what was good is you
know i don't have any black currant
jelly
because that [ __ ] is so good with black
currant jelly it is yeah
um i forgot all about it but you can use
you can use grape
with the [ __ ] white creamy gravy
creamy gravy this base
start off with roux add sour cream and
then i put cream
then parsley
[ __ ] was good i already had spaghetti
linguine he already cooked up from a
couple days before
instead of bow tie pasta i just put it
on [ __ ] spaghetti like a white
spaghetti it was good
you can run mashed potatoes too yeah
which i thought about
but i was kind of like well we already
have that pasta made so
i've got bow ties i got bow ties
i got bow ties you got both yeah but you
know i didn't
didn't really need it you could use bow
tie they were bow tie egg noodles
okay that's what you're really supposed
to eat it with
but i i kind of like them better with
mashed potatoes yeah i like them with
that's my favorite thing but you know we
did we you know we already had pasta
made and i was kind of like it's dumb to
like leave all that pasta in the
refrigerator and what would you just eat
it with that
um yeah what's up uh i feel like oh tila
said something about
uh her that she had a cat that would
fight full songs
full-size dogs yeah some cats aren't
afraid of anything one thing pookie
is not she's little she's never been
hurt so she's not afraid of you she is
not afraid of
anything she's not afraid of us
she's not afraid of beijing she's not
now if strangers come over the house
she'll hide in the bed for a little
while and like look
out like what is this all about but
i don't i mean the few times we've had
she was outside and there was like
animals and [ __ ] in the backyard she
just kind of like went up to that [ __ ]
and it's like
what's this what's this all about you
know what i mean she's not afraid of
anybody
it's funny because beijing you can
imagine
when we first got pokey when she was and
like i said she was very small i think
she was only six
weeks old eight weeks old her eyes were
still blue
um you know so she was quite little i
have a video of her from
way back then when we felt when we first
thought she was a boy i think it was
only the first or second day that we had
her
and she was kind of hiding under the bed
but she was kind of coming out and like
playing with [ __ ]
and even from that like beijing was
super not happy about it because she's
like what i'm the baby
i don't like this there's a new baby
yeah everybody's paying attention to
that
i'm not happy about it but she kind of
became the old lady though
because before that i mean beijing's
always been real aloof
i mean ever since i mean she's what 12
13 years old yeah she doesn't even like
you picking her up anymore
yeah if you pick her up now she's like
she can totally indignant
issue anything but she'll just be like
okay
and why she'll be like that i bleached
that kitchen floor today and she went
[ __ ] crazy she loves the smell of
bleach she tried to [ __ ] the damn mop
just yeah she interesting
like like beijing loves bleach
more than catnip oh yeah it's much more
in canada big time
she goes crazy i think i have a video
that the last time like um
one time when i bleached the our
bathroom
and she came in there and she was just
rolling all she rolled all over the
floor she rolled over the shower mat she
was just like oh my god
bleach had her [ __ ] up she was rolling
around
high off the bleach and i'm petting her
every time i [ __ ] pet her she's
i know i could hear her i just she's
been here in the office that i get like
what the challenge is matter with her
he's like i'm bleaching stuff and i was
like yeah
yeah she was telling me how good it was
she's so good it was making her weird
and yeah and it's like i thought that
was like i thought she was just like had
some problems
no but when i looked it up it's like
apparently
some cats like dolls like that and
ragdolls in particular which she is
um are really really into bleach smell
she's rolling around and you're
you're patting her and she's furious and
she's not
it's she can't take it she can't take it
but it's like some kind of a weird
sexual [ __ ] thing
like more than like picture like you
know how catnip you know how they get
all like [ __ ] high on [ __ ] yeah it's
like that but we're
ten times worse yeah i mean she just
like rolls around she's like
she's ah my god she [ __ ] loves it i
didn't get that [ __ ] on video i'll post
it up
i have a video but it's not i i missed
like the best part of it because i was
running to get my because i'm like oh my
god look what she's doing that i'm ready
to get my camera
she won't bite you but she kind of you
can feel like she wants to
maybe wants to but she won't it's it's
not
anger it's just it's ecstasy
yeah she just can't take it so it's like
every time we
clean the bathroom like with bleach it's
like you have to kind of like
keep her away from it because i don't
want her drinking the [ __ ] or licking it
off the floor
she's insane but pookie doesn't really
seem to care about me
but beijing [ __ ] loves it man she
just wants it all over her fur
she'll roll all over the floor i don't
get it it's crazy
i've never seen anything like it but
like i said it's not
i guess it's not completely
unprecedented because i have when i
searched it like i googled it and some
people did say that
their cats like went crazy for bleach
and particularly ragdolls do yeah and
that's what she is
but t you need to start your own channel
t you and your husband
yeah yeah she's she she's talkative
she'll get it she'll get in the damn
comment sections
she'll keep me [ __ ] talking too
you know i'm talking about well i'm only
talkative when i drink
yeah and then it's like the next day i
don't remember anything
there's always i mean we got a lot of we
got a lot of good
um listeners and stuff and patrons yeah
you guys
but it's kind of like when you're doing
the show you're looking into this
into the stream and you're kind of like
focusing on who's talking the most and
people that are making good comments and
it it makes it easier on us because it
feels like i'm just doing the show for
only like a couple people instead of
like
a bunch of them these things some of
these things get thousands of hits
well it's always easier to like and
easier to focus like i have to say that
some of you
that some of you guys in the chat are
like funnier than we are yeah
i was saying t needs her own show so
some of you guys should totally start
your own channel because
you're easily funnier than we are yeah
because you come up with like some
[ __ ] funny ass comments that like
[ __ ] crack man
but yeah so uh yeah teila said that's
how uh pinot was
she hated other cats most humans and all
dogs who were lucky if she liked you
i mean pookie is
uh she's pretty friendly but like i said
if if we have like friends over or
strangers over
she doesn't like that she's wary but
if you hang out for an hour or two then
she'll be like
all right i'll come out and like you can
pet me that's cool
but the weird thing is that beijing you
remember when sophie came over
yeah beijing immediately
and like i said beijing is very aloof
it's like she will
sit in my lap every now and then if
she's lonely like she'll come in the
office and be like yeah okay
but if you try to pet her she's like so
became twice though didn't she
yeah yeah and the second time sophie
came
basers was just as soon as sophie came
in the house
as soon as she came in yeah she tried to
climb up her yeah she was like
i remember she was hugging yeah yeah and
she was like rolling
around in a club screaming and [ __ ] yeah
which i never saw that before no
but she will come up like beijing is
like in a way
she's aloof but she's more curious than
pookie because if you come over
like beijing will come she won't
necessarily come up to you
although she did to sophie but like when
our friends come over
they'll kind of she'll come up and like
smell your bags
like if you have a purse or something or
a coat or something
like she'll come up and like lay in that
and be like and like check that out
and then she'll be like yeah all right
you're all right we had a wild party
over here one time all the [ __ ] a
whole [ __ ] goth scene
i remember that party yeah dimitri came
set up his [ __ ] dj equipment
we had [ __ ] lights and [ __ ] smoke
machines in here [ __ ] setting off the
dab of smoke detectors i didn't i didn't
realize that
that that a smoke machine was set off
smoke detectors but it did once it got
[ __ ] strong enough yeah well the
neighbors are like what the [ __ ] is
going on in there at least nobody called
the police on yeah and
i was afraid of that yeah and [ __ ]
basis was hiding
she didn't want to go and she was like
no [ __ ] this
but if a couple people come over she
just comes out and like smells your
bags dom the bomb gave us uh four
pounds and 99 cents awesome thank you
dom the bomb
said tom and jenny thanks for the great
shows you as well thank you very much
giving us those uh british money british
money the british monies
yeah pound sterling five pound sterling
that sounds like so it sounds so awesome
it sounds like it weighs something
it sounds like it's worth more it does
yeah
well it just it reminds me of back in
the old days when my dad used to have
like some silver bars
you know what i mean which i used to be
like fascinated by even though they
weren't worth anything back then really
but um he had a few of them yeah sophie
was gonna come
she was gonna come to uh back what was
that about a month ago
but she had family problems and you know
and then she had a new job that she was
starting up so
she couldn't make it she's doing some
kind of contract right now for
like a local government agency paperwork
stuff
i mean probably if you're gonna come
down to florida it's better to like not
come in the summertime
i'm gonna not get a lie unless you like
beach stuff unless you like being sticky
and sweaty and having swamp bats all the
time
oh it's not that bad jenny yes it is you
have people that come here for the
summer
and then to sit out on a pool and drink
tropical drink
drinks and swim and get sun and
you know there there's some people like
it's just that you don't like it well
yeah but the thing about it is that if
you're just on vacation for a week or
two
and you're just laying by a pool and
like drinking margaritas and [ __ ] yeah
it's probably pretty awesome then
especially
if you came from somewhere cold but if
you have to live here all the time
esther has sent us not so fun ten
dollars thank you esther thank you jenny
and tom for being you
and she sent us 9.99
yeah it is because well you know i'm not
going to say anything because if i say
something sideways and like the [ __ ]
i'll lose the strength yeah no need for
me too so i was wondering who the high
goth girl was
hanging out in the background when i was
new yeah that's sophie yeah
sophie was a listener yeah well still is
yeah she's in the chat sometimes i don't
i don't see her
not here tonight she was a listener and
then it turned out
that her sister
is friends with a little sister
of one of my best friends growing up and
i was growing up in michigan yeah so
we're actually from the same
neighborhood in a way
yeah you know [ __ ]
so you know so soap is kind of like
extended family
and it's funny because she just found us
at random as a listener
but that was just a weird coincidence
it's a small
word after all not really i think i
think
certain people i think the force there's
guidance
behind the force there's something about
people that come from
like environments in the past gravitate
so you're so you're likely to meet
people
who were in some way connected to you
well because you have a
you have like a cultural uh similarity
yeah culturally and so you're going to
be into
the same kind of stuff so you're going
to gravitate to the same kind of things
and i think i had mentioned michigan and
detroit yeah
and we and she's from the goth scene
yeah i think that was the beginning of
it so she started to become a listener
and it turned out
that we have roots in the same area when
i'm not from there
but i moved there but you live in high
school yeah or later
and i [ __ ] had a good club scene back
in the late 80s before i joined the army
and went to high school there for two
years i liked michigan
i couldn't live in michigan today um
there's just not enough going on you
know i mean i don't like to be that far
north yeah i i prefer the south
um i've been all over the united states
and the world
even i had i had a good time in boston i
couldn't live there now though
i don't i couldn't live in new york city
even though i liked new york city
i liked new yorkers better than
bostonians actually
i always like to new york they're a
little more hard-edged i like them a
little bit more a little more realistic
people well they're kind of cranky and
i'm kind of cranky yeah a lot of people
that were in boston were not from boston
they moved there
to go to go to school when i was there
and they're all trying to be something
that they're not they're kind of
touristy and
toy toy and [ __ ] well the thing the
thing that
new yorkers and i think this is the
reason why a lot of people particular
types of people like new york is just
because it's a very no [ __ ]
yeah kind of place you know what i mean
which is something that i really likes
about it new york is the
is is the metropolitan version of
mississippi they're not [ __ ] playing
around a lot of time
the ones that were born and raised there
a lot of people just move there they'll
just tell you [ __ ] to your face and it's
like they're not worried about whether
you don't like it or not
yeah that's like that new guy who's
trying that new guy who's trying to
become
uh i think it's the mayor oh yeah that
black dude he was telling all these
[ __ ]
because the [ __ ] new york's [ __ ] up
right now and he's turned around and
he's [ __ ] blaming all the people that
moved there in the past 15 years
you guys moved into our [ __ ] you guys
[ __ ] it up and now you want to run
after you [ __ ] [ __ ] it up and we're
staying here we got to fix this
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] hilarious i don't
think he's won yet
but that dude actually does need to be
the mayor i forgot i forgot his name
but he's just a black new yorker and he
[ __ ] told the truth
y'all [ __ ] moved here from california
and [ __ ] our city
up and then you ran
i don't know i always liked it there
it's not it's not as scuzzy as it was in
the 70s
and i understand that that had some kind
of charm to it yeah
um but i don't know i i've been there
many times but
and i've always really liked it yeah you
know it's kind of dirty but
actually i think old new york me and you
would like that better
probably although like i said i liked
detroit
when detroit was yeah was opposed to
pocahontas like i said it did have a
kind of charm to it
yeah it did post apocalyptic detroit
with detroit was pretty cool because
i got an entire floor out of a building
that had a [ __ ] drive
in cattle slaughter elevator it was a
cattle slaughter house that had been
converted into like a four-story like
apartments
but they weren't really apartments each
floor was an apartment i only paid like
350 bucks a month for it
i would drive my car into the into the
cattle lift and then
it would take me up to my floor and i'd
drive it into my apartment and none of
the [ __ ] floor plan made any goddamn
sense
it was like something out of a skinny
puppy video
it was [ __ ] cool there was no heating
or air conditioning you just had to
[ __ ] suck it up you needed to [ __ ]
had to plug in at that and i was there
for like a year and never paid
electricity
enter never paid any utilities nobody
ever asked me
i just paid well see this is why they
had such a good
like this is why they had all these
[ __ ] awesome bands and [ __ ]
yeah because they were all squatters
they all have that kind of like
situation you're in a row era
yeah where it's just kind of like you
would just move into a building it's
like has anybody noticed that i'm not
here i'm not paying about those okay
well they haven't been like they had a
whole abandoned skyscrapers
right brave enough to move into them
they had abandoned houses you could move
into that look brand new
they were victorian style brick
victorian
yeah era [ __ ] victorian style
[ __ ] houses now those neighborhoods
are all torn down now
but when i was there you could move into
you could just move into a random block
well like i said and it would have
like power that was the weirdest thing
you it would have power and water
yeah and you wouldn't know who owned it
and they had people doing that
and you know it was i mean if you could
live somewhere for free and like
city clubs hall the shelter
and you know that's where i saw that's
where the [ __ ] beginning of the
[ __ ] goth fixation
happened going down a city club seeing
them [ __ ] ass girls on the [ __ ]
fishnets and underwear fishnet stockings
and
it all comes back off sluttyness
i showed up and i go man i'm not cool
we're not cool enough for this [ __ ]
and [ __ ] i'm not cool i had a good
time there though
it was the beginning of the saga
i was [ __ ] seeing dude some skinny
popular right there i didn't know who
the [ __ ] they were
yeah skinny puppy that's a cool name for
a band you know
i didn't know who i was oh my god yeah
well you know about a year later you
know it was
about a year later [ __ ] i was a
little bit more on top of the game but
then i [ __ ] went to went to the army
yeah well i moved back to mississippi
for a few months and then went to the
army
when the [ __ ] war broke out i was
like man i gotta go to this
i gotta go to the [ __ ] first goal
four so
you know boy does what he does
you know a boy does what he does boy
does what he does
i need another drink man yeah is your
[ __ ] empty uh
no not yet are we still making them yeah
okay
yeah still going there thank you esther
this is the well that's what i mean like
my shit's way behind so it's like if i'm
kind of like way [ __ ] i was like he's
got his chat over there which i'm glad
but my [ __ ] is probably like [ __ ]
five or ten minutes behind so i'm sorry
about that
because my [ __ ] keeps uh it keeps
freezing up
but i just keep on going because
i don't want it to you know what i mean
so it's like that's why i keep looking
at [ __ ] because i'm looking at my laptop
and my laptop is not moving
so i'm always kind of like is it still
going is it still going then i have to
look over there and i'm like okay it's
still going
but yeah so even though it's like and
the thing about it too is that even my
obs
is like even when it's running correctly
which it's not
it's 10 seconds behind there's a 10
second lag
so he's like always 10 seconds ahead of
me but now he's probably like 5 or ten
minutes ahead just because i've
had it that freeze up on me somebody's a
computer is not processing but very fast
yeah clearly well like i said for the
live stream i might have to like
tone down the resolution maybe that
would help
but i'll do that for a friday show i'll
try it out because
i mean i don't have any i don't have it
at like maximum
[ __ ] resolution or anything it's not
like i'm trying to like stream the [ __ ]
at [ __ ] super hd
i'm just like it regular but
i don't know i don't want it to look
like crap but
i don't know i don't know what else to
do at this point because
i don't know i told him i was like dude
just like a few months ago i just paid
like 300 something dollars for this
which is a lot of money and
it's just not working and that really
really makes me mad
when i spend 300 something dollars on
something and it doesn't work the way
it's supposed to
and there's really nothing else on this
computer the only thing i use
this laptop for is streaming because i
have other
this computer right here is for you know
my desktop computer that's for video
editing and various other things and
then i have a mac over here that which
is for graphic design
this is my streaming computer and it's
not
doing what it's supposed to be doing and
that makes me very very angry
[Laughter]
but you know what i mean uh yeah esther
said my boyfriend got me hooked on the
13 o'clock show
that's so that's awesome it's like
it's so funny because i don't know i
feel like we started this show back in
[ __ ]
summer of 2016. we started it
just for shits and giggles honestly
we were at a [ __ ] um
what was it it was at that comic book
store
but uh what's the name of it [ __ ] it's
in orlando somewhere
i guess it's still around and they were
doing like kind of an event
and we had a table there and i was
selling some of my books
and um armando's emilia was there who
was a horror writer
and so we were talking to him and he's
like
you know he was talking to me about my
books and he was talking to you and [ __ ]
he's like you know you guys are really
funny it's like you guys should because
he had a podcast
and it's like you guys should start a
podcast you know i have a
he had a network at that point and it's
like you guys should start when you guys
are really funny and it's like you know
you could talk about whatever and you
could promote your books and i was like
oh yeah that's kind of a good idea so
when they were like kind of talking
about it
i'm like yeah let's just do like a
podcast about some weird [ __ ] we'll do
like some paranormal [ __ ] we'll do some
[ __ ]
true crime [ __ ] we'll do like whatever
and
i think when we first started out we
just did one show a week a week right
we just did like the main show yeah
which
is crazy to think about now and then we
were just trying to keep it to one hour
we had on that on his little network
before there was even a video [ __ ]
element to it
40 000 downloads did we
we were the we were their second highest
yeah 40 000
uh podcasts like as far as downloads
went like for the audio version right
it didn't make any difference though
because we had zero interaction from
those people
and made no money yeah i mean there came
a point where we were just kind of like
well we wanted a youtube component
yeah and at first i was just doing a
slideshow because we didn't have video
um so you know if you guys have seen
like the early ones
i don't even like i'm kind of i mean i'm
sure they're fine
but i'm kind of like i don't i don't
really like to go back and listen to the
old ones
i don't even i don't even know like well
yeah because we just had like a shitty
like cheap microphone because i was
totally totally broke then
and plus i was still like working
full-time like at
a regular job whereas nowadays
you know i have a bunch of side gigs but
this i mean honestly this
is kind of like my main job now i still
write books i still do freelance graphic
design whenever
[ __ ] comes in i saw some clients and
stuff but
we do so many shows now that this is
pretty much my main
job at this point yeah but you know
that's
cool that's fine and honestly it's like
i've been adding more shows like book
reviews and like i said i was talking
about earlier that
maybe i'll do like when october comes i
want to do like a
horror movie review like every day but
like i said i'm going to start early so
so i don't get like [ __ ] crunch time
like when it comes october
so i'll have them all like ahead of time
but i'm always like thinking of new [ __ ]
we can do
for the channel yeah so it's almost kind
of like i'm still gonna i'm still
working on the true crime book i'm still
doing all that stuff but
what's the thing is with this show and
in our
in our subscribers is that it's small
and fluid enough to where
we can add new elements and drop them as
we go we can be very
like the cooking stuff we can do that
every now and then but if we drop that
never go back to it it's not gonna make
a big big difference
as long as we stick with the saturday
main show that we do or it's friday
night or first should be a friday night
we can do it we can pretty much do what
we want well and yeah
like i kind of like the freedom of just
having thing
and you know i really liked doing thank
you very much victor victor gates sent
us 10
super chat thank you i started listening
in 2017
when i was delivering dominoes on the
weekends in nursing school
today vic man [ __ ] thank you for
saying so
i wonder how this [ __ ] happens but that
was what i had
that's how i imagined the show working
people in their cars
and people doing things people on their
commutes from day one that's pretty much
the audience and people who were just
bored
they had that needed to kill time people
who are
out in the middle of nowhere and
isolated i kind of
based it off of what i got out of the
very old howard stern show
well you just wanted like a hangout
internet kind of atmosphere
yeah which we liked that like from the
very beginning because even like it's
like you liked howard stern
and a reality now and a reality element
i mean a lot of the youtube shows that i
liked
um i mean one that i discovered recently
is uh time suck which i really like
and his shows are usually like two two
and a half hours long
and he talks about mostly the same kind
of crap we talk about time
you know uh to true crime that kind of
crap and uh you know unsolved mysteries
history that kind of stuff
and he's a comedian so it's like really
funny and it's just him
but i mean i like [ __ ] like welcome to
the basement it was just two guys and
they were kind of watching a movie and
then they'd talk about the movie and
then they would talk about other movies
that they'd seen and they kind of had
this
back and forth they've been friends a
long time and i really really liked that
just hang out
casual sort of vibe i like that
my boy graham who was also from uh
michigan we went to high school together
he's a uh if you guys are new to the
show he's a retired police officer that
i grew up with
um he's asking does the show pay the
bills
the entire effort all wrapped up
together
bills it comes close but you gotta
understand that
it's multimedia there's the show there's
ad revenues
super chats then there's merchandise
then there's all the books that she has
selling yeah that's a whole different
thing
yeah the books and then there's the
audio books yeah
audio books were a big chunk too
um i really do think we need to move to
other platforms as certain platforms get
better
i think um i think odyssey is going to
be a good platform
uh it's still under construction but
it's it's a
it's going to be a good youtube
alternative that will have a live stream
and super chats and there's some kind of
this [ __ ] laptop we're gonna get
another laptop before we do it
but you can take your laptop and you
hook it up so you're streaming on
several platforms at once
and that's the way we need to go um i i
gotta get more into that technology
and then uh then you gotta understand
you know [ __ ] um
uh i got military retirement so i'm
making my active duty pay
yeah so he he can do nothing yeah i
could do nothing i don't need to work
which you know i get my active duty pay
and for a little frustrating for me yeah
she gets
she chills i can i can get i get my
active duty pay
and i get full medical yeah so see i
don't have any of that [ __ ]
yeah so it's basically like i'm just
kind of like what
how it breaks down probably i think
about
60 percent is um the show
and then maybe 20
book sales and then however much is left
over because i can't math
is graphic design i had a lot more
graphic design clients like i had
um i lost a couple in the past few years
because
you know the economy is kind of shitty
so
um you know so i haven't had this but i
do have like some
so i still get that it's irregular
but i would prefer that so actually i do
so this show doesn't pay all the bills
but
between this and my two other gigs which
i also have
um it's a i don't have a lot of extra
money
but you know it's not like i have a lot
left over but i do have enough to pay
the bills and like have a little bit
extra yeah
and you know our this is we're in a nice
place
um if this was say california and new
york
this would be [ __ ] seven thousand
eight thousand well i mean our cost of
living is fairly low
i mean low compared to the cost is low
compared to other major cities i mean
the rent
and like i said the rent on this place
this is a four bedroom
three bathroom house yeah um however
many square feet it is fifteen hundred
something like that something fourteen
hundred something i don't remember um
it's eighteen hundred a month that
includes laundry yes which you would
never have that that's what i was paying
almost
for an apartment in boston back in the
night and we kind of got a deal on it
because the people the the
people that are landlords like we know
them and they own a bunch of other
properties
so it's not like they're dying like this
is the only
property that they own so i gotta answer
some stuff here
yeah so we kind of got a deal on that
all right uh
the bills are kind of high
i mean you know for air conditioning
yeah
[ __ ] like that power electrical power
for the air conditioning yeah that's
kind of the biggest
groceries aren't really aren't that bad
not really um
okay gadget says i found 13 o'clock on
paranormal radio while
by driving a side loader at work heard a
movie review where a guy a girl were
swearing at each other love it still do
it
mother [ __ ] yeah um
see this is why i get into every single
time that we do a youtube video i always
have to mark that first thing that says
inappropriate language victor says i
don't remember how i found y'all um
uh danny uh ghostface says it's a sin
that this channel doesn't have a million
subscribers already
it's the best true crime paranormal
channel in my opinion
look man even though we wander off we're
thriving we're throttled
we do their their their favor youtube
favors uh corporate backed
shows okay so i know the throw all right
xanada says suzanne
xander and me [ __ ] uh do a lot of do
do a lot of stuff off the show talking a
lot
uh he's a good dude he says i listen to
old art bell and this show is so similar
that's a huge compliment because not
only did i really like
howard stern i loved [ __ ] art bell
and and i kind of wanted it to show
to feel like a combination of the two
art belt was [ __ ] really no one's
gonna art bell was the [ __ ] master
nori couldn't come close but art art was
the [ __ ]
george nori kind of like get on my
[ __ ] yeah i gotta admit
art was the [ __ ] he seemed like kind of
a condescending dude he was i mean you
know
not sorry george i'm just saying
[Laughter]
maybe he's a perfectly nice person i
don't know t says i stumbled upon tom
and jenny while searching for reviews
for blacula
ain't that something i love that movie i
do too yeah i listened to their review
and laughed my ass off it's the best
review of that movie on youtube thank
you very much
yeah i'll [ __ ] love black and and and
scream like you the scream
honestly i think i like scream blacula
scream a little bit better because it
has the voodoo
yeah and i love voodoo what was the one
with the what was the one with the
voodoo one with um
we saw that one [ __ ] i had uh pam grier
i need more information oh yeah yeah
that was really good oh [ __ ]
we needed to request it's on shutter
it's on shutter yeah i need to get that
on blue red and review it
um i'll probably think of it about 10
minutes she played a voodoo princess
yeah yeah i know what you're talking
about we just watched it not too long
yeah
i want to see it again sorry alcohol is
like
fogging my it's clouding my mind like on
the twilight zone
but um yeah it was on shutter yeah
but i can't remember what it was right
now
oh it's not ganjon hess it's the other
one
yeah grandpa says yeah i'm a pensioner
also life is good yeah
they're paying us they're paying for our
silence
[Laughter]
not working for you they're playing
they're paying for our you shoot your
mouth off yeah
well it's not the silence that you know
they don't want the profession that
professional silence okay have we looked
at tina says have you guys looked into
sponsors
i have actually yeah um we wanted to get
shuttered as far after us because
well i'm not begging them i wouldn't do
that but it's like if they wanted to
that would be awesome
a lot a super chat two dollars it's not
easy being green but it's easy being
but is it easy being red i don't know
uh yeah it is yeah because i
might i don't know if you guys know but
my natural hair color is red
yeah i haven't been a natural hair color
but that's what my natural hair color is
it's casanova's frankenstein said if
jenny had a holy fans channel to make a
lot of money just saying i know dude i'm
yeah i'm gonna hook that up bro don't
worry about it we're gonna get a little
bit one of these days
i might if i get broke enough
i can break a buddy i mean you know
like i said it's it's good it's like
i've got to a point in my life
that i wanted to get to which is like i
don't have to go
to a job every day
and listen to stupid people telling me
what to do
i only have to listen to you telling me
what to do which is also annoying but
you know
you just missed authority party says i
found you guys through the golden state
killer arrest news
oh okay you guys got me through a
horrible stomach flu three years ago i
loved you ever since thank you very much
that's so awesome isn't that awesome
yeah victor victor garcia says i love i
used to love coast to coast until when i
had turned into the show's topic it
was just i used to love coast to coast
until one night i tuned in
and the show's topic was back pain i'm
like what the [ __ ]
yeah every now and then yeah every now
and then they'd have a [ __ ] up [ __ ]
topic yeah i think they might have had
something to do with sponsors telling
them to do that
yeah let's do it back maybe it was like
sponsored by do you know what it's it's
like
[ __ ] funny but like i remember
something like my mom told me like a
long time ago about back pain
she was like oh yeah back pain that's
just like [ __ ] you need some
laxatives
yeah esther says vicky's sponsored by
doanes
esther says uh victor once tom creates
and publishes boopapedia
they'll make some decent cash yeah i
probably would do
i just pictured that whole book in my
head
you know how i do yeah t what movie was
that had pam grier in it she played the
uh the voodoo princess
god damn it we just watched it isn't she
also kind of like a
private investor yes same thing damn it
what the [ __ ] was the name of it we just
[ __ ] watched it it's on shutter
they just added it not too long ago god
damn it
ah it wasn't abby that was the
possession one donna bomb says i picked
up shutter because of you two so it'd be
a good sponsor yeah from day one we love
shutter we got our shutter subscription
for 4.9.9 a month i think it was the
first time yeah i just i went
um i went annual a few months ago
because they were offering a thing it's
like
uh i think it was 59 for the year 56
for the year and then you got a free
t-shirt so i got a shutter shirt
and i was like yeah yes please give me
that [ __ ] and honestly
i've been really happy with because
every single week
i check in every thursday to see what
they added
and it's like i love they add like two
or three brand new movies
and then they added like a whole bunch
of like old ones
so it's like really it's really well
curated
plus they have a lot of giallo which i'm
all about it
you know what i mean no no t it wasn't
it wasn't uh scream back of the screen
there was no another one
she did she did another movie
google it no well i can't
get another movie and it was taking
place i think it was in new orleans
wasn't it
and it had something to do with private
investigators and cops i want to see it
again
it went by fast and and warlocks
and [ __ ] voodoo
it wasn't a vampire movie though i've
never seen it no it was good
yeah it was good it was i'll probably
remember like
i don't remember like 15 minutes from
now victor says i think i just googled
paranormal podcast or something
yeah which is like really funny
we don't do a lot of paranormal stuff
anymore i feel like we did a lot of
paranormal stuff
early on and then we kind of ran out of
paranormal sometimes
victor says shutter sucks thought
thought but i bought a year package i
don't know what he means by that victor
shutter is good for old stuff and new
stuff
like [ __ ] old stuff and do stuff the old
classic stuff is on there the hammer
horror stuff
well and have all the new series that
are they just added a bunch of like old
like vincent price stuff
yeah like house on haunted hill 13 goes
all that stuff
they just added a bunch of old silent
movies which is awesome they added a
bunch of old um
like bellagos stuff like a white zombie
they added a bunch of that
and then they had like a bunch of new
ones too was it sugar hill
yes sugar hill thank you thank you
mr roboto sent a super chat of five
dollars thank you
do you know penny dreadful if so would
you go frankenstein
knowing you would regain memory that's
immortal and super strong i've never
seen page raffle
i saw the first season which i actually
really enjoyed
but i haven't seen any of the other
seasons yeah santa's
to be honest i don't know how you guys
can just sit there watching movies i
can't do it i'm too adhd
yeah i know man i could barely get you
to watch [ __ ] one movie i got him to
watch a [ __ ] apocalypse now and then
he watched it like 20 times
and got obsessed although you're like
worse than me because i can sit and
watch like three or four horror movies
in a row and you can't do that canada
telling you man if you like [ __ ]
apocalypse redux
see jeremiah johnson and c [ __ ] conan
but you got to get good copies kodam won
that's all
millions so it's all john milius and he
[ __ ]
writes those badass stories man there's
always
man story man story well it's not just
man stories it's life stories
he also he also did um um
[ __ ] uh red dawn red dawn is a good
one man
i want to see that one again i want to
get red dawn they remade that i think
red yeah i want to see the original a
red red dawn got millions banned from
from from hollywood they're like we
can't take this anymore they're like we
can't take this
although like i said they could take it
because they remade raped on
yeah they did like fairly recently yeah
though
you know but like i said that's that's
kind of the thing it's like
they act like oh we can't deal with it
but yeah they acted but they went back
to it
yeah well anything that's like an in an
ip that everyone recognizes
yeah they're going to read but in those
days they told millions he had to go
but then years went on decades went on
then they want to come [ __ ] remake
it's not as good though from what i
heard yeah tila said sugar okay yeah
yeah yeah that's it yeah we just watched
that like not too long ago i can't
believe i didn't remember the name of
that
i'm drunk sorry yeah yeah no need for me
says first penny driver was awesome i
really really liked the first season
yeah i really need to watch like more of
the [ __ ] but like i said it's like i'm
running out of time for
uh yeah xanada there's another movie
there's another movie in it
and um that if you like millions you
want to see it
and uh that was
let me see i think that was v i think it
was victor it was hernandez
sent me the big lebowski my i think it
was hernandez wouldn't it
i handed somebody think so and the big
lebowski
one i can't believe you never saw that
oh man was [ __ ] i saw that like back
when it came out
one of the characters in the big
lebowski
was modeled after john milius yeah
and what's his name that dude from
[ __ ] from uh
uh what's that tv series the john
goodman john goodman
yeah john good john goodman plays him he
talks about
it he plays me as a vietnam vet and he's
all [ __ ] kind of like sorry [ __ ] up
donnie
yeah yeah you got to see big labels but
you want to see um you want to see
conan one get a good copy of that in hd
all right and then you want to see
jeremiah johnson one of those two first
gen
you'd like jeremiah that's [ __ ]
really good all about man values man
values and then
and then then you can go see [ __ ] big
lebowski that's [ __ ] funny
yeah it's good i always like the big
lebowski yeah but it's just kind of like
well yeah it's just funny uh i i feel
like you missed out on a lot of like
indie films yeah probably like during a
certain time period
because gadget three sent five pounds
thank you fair chance i'll fall asleep
gonna try and stay up though
i'm stellared okay
dom the bomb says jenny i love italian
films as well but i'm a big sucker for
italian spaghetti westerns the most
i just like i don't know there's just
something
that is there's something just very
distinctive about italian
horror films and it's not just yes they
loved the gore
which yeah i love that but there was
some
like i don't know like they had some
kind of like aesthetic quality about
them
i love giallo movies i don't know what
it is and it's just kind of like even
shitty ones i'll watch them all day long
okay yeah um t says she's never seen the
big lebowski you got to see it
but it turns out turns out it's not at a
scene to big lebowski about the rug
tying the rims together but yeah yeah
that one dude that's supposed to be
amelia's
yeah and then um somebody said um
don the bomb says conan what is the
meaning of life
the meaning of life is what conan said
it was all right
[ __ ] you know where's that shirt i
bought you i got it in there
crush your enemies see him driven before
you it says
here to [ __ ] lamentation other women
i get in that
[ __ ] people up watch them run away
listen to their women crying
the most important what that all boils
down to what [ __ ] conan is saying
all right what is most important in life
winning
winning is most important in life what
are you talking about
you are forged on the anvil of chrome
all right
your pain forges you into something
that's
strong and hard you know but it's fun
too this is not a bad process well it's
fun for you it's probably not
fun for the other people that you're
stopping it's loss and [ __ ] well no
if you stomp on [ __ ] because
they they needed it
they asked for it did they if they
attacked you
conan wasn't cruel conan was cool to
people i'm just fine they [ __ ] with
him he [ __ ] smashed him
yeah i know what you do you know how it
is
no i know he's not your [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
you you know you gotta you're only on
your first hat
yo that's right [ __ ] that's how you do
it though so yeah
you're [ __ ] up now they're bringing
up you need to go to like defcon
yeah three yeah three def con three no
definite two
that gets to def con too not at one yet
okay defcon too i don't know what you're
like
[ __ ] redneck hat right there where
the [ __ ] camouflage is just
camouflaged
oh [ __ ] but no i'm defcon too right now
and that's because i was talking about i
feel well i feel
i feel like defcon 1 should be your
michael kane wig
no [ __ ] defcon 1 is when the [ __ ]
nuclear bombardment has [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying so it should be
the new when it's hit
no talking about afternoon happier
michael caitanya it's yeah
it's after the [ __ ] nuclear strike
has happened this is your
sexual tyrannosaurus i'm just a sexual
traumatic star right now yeah
right why do i ignore this stuff
because you understand the myth this is
my this is my life you understand the
mythos of tom
this is my life you guys no it's not
here
it's just a sideshow it is i yeah i do
have to like kind of
crack yeah i have to keep track of like
the tom mythology
because at some point at some point i'm
sure i'm going to be asked to like
write
don't let all this [ __ ] vanish like
dust in the wind
yeah same yeah it's like yep that's what
i mean nobody cares about my ass
tell tom to watch fargo see
i've never seen it you need to see
fargo tom's thought on oh my god it's so
good
tom's thought on the sequel conan and
the destroyer okay
conan the destroyer a lot of controversy
behind it
okay yeah it was first of all milius
wasn't involved in that
okay so it did not have the [ __ ]
mythic quality
milius was going to write a trilogy like
star wars which they should have let him
do
yeah all right and it was [ __ ]
conan this in his youth conan
[ __ ] kind of like middle-aged and
conan is an old man
all right it had to do with [ __ ]
rising
uh [ __ ] uh becoming uh what was the
what was the word that he said
uh anyway [ __ ] what to do once you
have power
and then the third one was the
repercussions of all that
yeah the ramifications of it and how do
you remain
relevant in old age and it was going to
be like prehistoric star wars
it was going to be really good which
would have been yeah
brilliant somebody still needs to do
that it was all
nichian [ __ ] from friedrich nietzsche
it's germanic philosophy
hollywood didn't like that especially at
that time
all right um john millius was jewish
but other but he was right-wing he was
jewish in the way of like
ariel sharon was jewish you know he was
like
like an israeli [ __ ] warrior you know
that's that's
the other guys in hollywood
the jewish guys were not like that they
were i guess you could say they were
lefty
you know and uh they thought this [ __ ]
was all
they looked at that [ __ ] and they're
like that's all germanic philosophy
what's up with all this fascist nazi
stuff
which is a total mischaracterization of
nietzsche
and his philosophy nichian philosophy
was actually eastern
it's eastern in origin it's very yin
and yang almost it's a it's a germanic
interpretation of buddhism
is what it is and the teachings of
siddhartha
if that man ever existed i don't think
he ever did yeah i kind of doubt that i
think it's legit
okay um
conan destroyer came out they didn't go
with the mythic version uh that
that that milius wanted they went with
something that was
closer to to marvel comic books
so and they didn't really have the
budget to pull that off yeah
they wanted it to be pg to get more kids
in the theater and watch it
they wanted to be more colorful they
wanted it to be
kind of like subject matters and more
what you saw in the comic books
i disagree with that direction but
that was the direction that they took
and i don't know it may have made more
money than the first one i doubt it
honestly you could probably do that
better nowadays
yeah nowadays um because people have
more nowadays people have more
patience more understanding for um
you know a wider universe and
also going into a movie with like this
is going to be
a trilogy and you're setting up the
whole thing ahead of time
i don't feel like they were doing that
so much back then now there's a channel
called midnight's edge
and they had a guy who was in kind of
like the what's his name ron
uh howard you know who's
howard was the name of the guy right
wait ron howard was the guy that
was like on happy days yeah okay
no no howard was was robert e howard i
think is what the guy's name was oh the
guy that wrote cody yeah yeah robert
howard
yeah the robert i didn't know who you're
talking about there was a guy who owns
the rights to robert e howard's work and
it's some kind of a um
um he he's kind of he's trying to
conserve it
and and make sure that it was a close
interpretation of howard's work
he likes the way milius did some [ __ ]
but he wants to do it
something like that with the same kind
of gravitas
but closer to what howard did in the
books
that's who you want to keep your eye on
if they do this hollywood will not be
able to execute this because of the
subject matter
they would instantly label that [ __ ] as
toxic masculinity
they'd cancel that [ __ ] out and talk
[ __ ] about it and they probably wouldn't
want it to be
shown in theaters so it would have to be
a independent film with
streaming which this is this technology
and this culture is now coming to
fruition
a good example is mst 3000
netflix didn't want to pick them up they
went directly to their fans
and got all the [ __ ] money they need
almost 8 million dollars
6.5 million 6.5 they had a kickstarter
yep to do an entire season a high
quality mst
13 episodes 13 so
so excited the hollywood theater system
is obsolete
all right as the technology and the new
market
[ __ ] evolves hopefully we will see
a good conan again although like i said
people like to complain about [ __ ]
nowadays it's like oh
this that and the other but i do kind of
feel like
something like conan as a trilogy like
you said
uh you know youth maintaining your power
how do you maintain your power in old
age as a trilogy
i think that would fly a lot more now
than it would have back then
because back then they made the first
movie it was successful but then the
second one we're like well we want more
kids to watch this we're gonna like put
some stupid monsters in it
that like like shitty makeup so it's
like they did
crappy [ __ ] like that they [ __ ] it up
they [ __ ] up the second one
yeah it had good [ __ ] in it but
they cheaped out on a lot of stuff they
wanted to make it more kid-friendly like
[ __ ] that
i feel like nowadays you could
make a series out of that or a trilogy
out of that even on netflix or something
like that
and it would be a lot better i feel like
there's more of an
audience for it nowadays the audiences
nowadays are more sophisticated they're
more
used to seeing things in that context
and it's also more you can also make
money targeting directly
right so [ __ ] wasn't better back then
because it's like they did the same
crappy
[ __ ] back then where they were trying to
like target kids and it's like it just
didn't work out
let me back off of this a little bit the
studio systems pretty much
always sucked always yeah that's what
i'm saying they're
trying to make money they don't know
what's going to make money
so they suck now more than they ever did
what's his name um uh childish gambino
just came out yesterday and says
all the new movies suck because
everybody's afraid to get canceled
it's all church ladies running the [ __ ]
now okay
so you would never see that conan would
ins they would label conan toxic
masculinity wouldn't happen
but it always sucked it just sucked in a
different way
the studio system and like hold on let
me finish
the the movies that you are [ __ ]
lusting over
all right as as young guys i'm not too
much talking to girls even though some
of the girls are the [ __ ]
[ __ ] like terminator one predator one
star wars
[ __ ] conan these were damn near
independent films
back even back then uh
conan was was conan and flash gordon
was dino de laurentiis studios that dude
was [ __ ] nuts
all right he would dump a lot of money
into a very risky projects
i loved those movies but they were they
weren't they were kind of failures in a
way
financially at the box office yeah they
made money they made their money back
but that studio went
under because of all that artsy fartsy
[ __ ] that they were doing and all those
risks they were taking
some of the more hollywood versions they
knew how to make a buck off a real
generic [ __ ]
okay they can make a buck off of that i
think they're aged out over time
but and then you look at lucasfilm
you know with star wars the very first
one that was an independent film
if a big hollywood studio had made that
it it wouldn't have had would have never
had a classical score
it had a disco score for that time
it would have a lot of [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] up at that time
it never would have aged as well as it
did that's still a classic movie
but a big studio couldn't do that
today because of the technology the new
appearance for a [ __ ] high quality
earth shattering high budget independent
films are starting to come back
so yeah you could do a conan sure but it
would have to be crowdsourced
it'd have to be streamed it would have
to go through the hot
that that robert e howard [ __ ] dude
who i saw i
listened to him talk and he he knows
what he's doing with conan
he knows what he's doing but i'm just
saying there's an audience out there
there's not a sport now which like i
said
back in the day you wouldn't have had
that right so i know people like to piss
and moan about [ __ ] nowadays but it's
like way better
it's better to because there's more
freedom it's like
people aren't making the move that's the
difference
they came out with the new cone and it
sucked what was that 2011
2009 i didn't see it i had jason momoa i
think
played oh yeah yeah that's right all
right i didn't see it though it it was
not a bad looking movie it did it did
not have the grand juror
of the [ __ ] of the milius de
laurentiis movie
it it certain elements of
it were kind of like a co-man comic book
um but it just didn't have the realism
in it there was something about arnold
schwarzenegger's conan that also was
good you know what i mean it was what
was in well he's kind of iconic as that
character so if you see it as another
actor it's not quite the same
yeah you know which i you know i get
that
the newer guy that they had he was a
muscular guy but there's the dude
has to look like a [ __ ]
niechian ubermensch he has to look like
a superhuman
and the only guy that would come close
today even though he's a little bit old
to be the rock
the rock could probably do a fantastic
conan
although he's too funny he's funny but
he's very likable
and he did have i'm not sure you want
conan to be likeable though
like not in the same way and the house
is likable
in the howard books he was not silent no
i know that
but he he had i feel like i love the
rock but he's been in too many like
comedic
roles or like crossover kind of rules i
don't know if anybody could see him you
need a rock like a character
sure somebody said somebody like that
yeah
and he has to have he has to be
physically very powerful
um it would help if he was kind of
racially ambiguous
that you really couldn't tell what race
he was because this is all stuff that's
either prehistoric
or it's way in the future in
post-apocalyptic
and he's a sumerian
not a sumerian a simmerian and nobody
knows what a sumerian looks like
we just made that shout out totally made
up oh
uh howard said it in a fictional
prehistoric era but the guy
but it was it was stone what's his name
with the director of [ __ ]
um he's a director of stone oliver
oliver stone oliver stone started on the
first drafts of the [ __ ]
script that arnold was in and in his
mind
it was post-apocalyptic very much in the
future
but mankind had gone
back like teenage caveman well i've
never seen it
but society had been destroyed thousands
of years ago
yeah that was the premise of teenage man
the roger corbin movie from the
late 50s right that everyone thought
that it was like caveman days but
spoiler in the future it was the spoiler
after after anything and because it was
the future that's how you could
that's how you could justify dog-headed
men and
monsters and gigantic spiders because
they were all
mutants genetically engineered stuff
yeah you can do all kind of functions
yeah
survive apocalypse you know
but you know like i said it's kind of
like i feel like
today it's a much better environment
i mean as i said we're old so
sometimes it seems like you know it's
like oh everything was better in the 70s
and 80s
it wasn't though because you still i
mean the classic movies
i mean at least as far as horror is
concerned because that's kind of like my
main thing
you know classic movies i love 70s
horror movies i love 80s horror movies
but they still had to work within the
studio system or at least
you know they had to be like independent
of the studio so there were really only
two things going on
whereas i feel like nowadays you kind of
have
almost endless outlets
i mean there are so many streaming
services there are so many
um you know services that are making
original content
that there's just so much [ __ ] that you
can't even sort because even me as like
somebody that likes horror
and i'm just trying to see all the best
[ __ ] that's new
and i'm trying to like review it and
stuff it's like i can't
get through all the stuff there's so
much of it
and there's so much good stuff there's a
lot of bad [ __ ] too but that's
always been yeah i just feel like
um i think people concentrate too much
as like oh there's all this [ __ ]
nowadays but it's like kind of like
there's a lot of
um there's a glut of good [ __ ] too it's
just harder to find
just because there's so much there are
so many streaming services
everybody's doing their own [ __ ]
nowadays like i said
you know you see horror movies i saw a
horror movie that was on amazon prime
that had been funded through kickstarter
and it was totally decent
you know what i mean it was totally
enjoyable yeah i totally watched it and
it's just like
i just kind of came across it randomly
and
so that's awesome to me like so i'm not
going to be like one of those cranky
pants like old people it's like ooh
everything's better back in the day
it totally wasn't like i'm not saying
that
you know some of the best movies ever
came out back then because they did but
in a way too
those movies are awesome because they
stood the test of time a lot of shitty
movies came out back then too
most but everybody even they're
forgotten everybody forgot about them
that's the thing and it's like i kind of
feel like people get into this thing
where
oh all the good [ __ ] came out back then
but it's like that's only because you
only remember the good [ __ ]
99 of the [ __ ] that came out back then
it was bad sucked
the same with the music sucked it sucked
and the only reason that you still
remember the [ __ ] because it was good
and it survived and the good [ __ ] that
comes out now
people will still remember it 10 20
years from now and it'll be the same
kind of thing
okay um what were they done
[ __ ] somebody was saying something let
me see
everybody's in there talking they're all
talking about movies see i just kind of
feel like like i said you have so many
streaming services nowadays
and people are willing to because it's
not super expensive anymore
to produce movies and shows the way it
used to be because it used to be super
expensive now you know
it's all that fat in there they were
[ __ ] stealing money and well and
now you can do it for fairly
inexpensively right i mean it's like
amazon prime has their own [ __ ] hulu has
their own [ __ ] every streaming service
has their own original content movies
were huge cash grabs too
well yeah it's just free [ __ ] money
yeah and so i feel like there's a lot
more
um you know there's a lot more kind of
like
you know there's a large expanse open
for
if you want to do like a three volume
like i said a three movie thing of conan
or you want to do like a new thing of
dune or you want to do an
adaptation of this book and i feel like
not only is that
feasible from a financial standpoint
but it's also feasible from a built-in
you have an audience for that yeah the
um
there and they're asking what about red
sonia nobody's mentioned that yeah red
sonja was
i remember red sonia but i haven't seen
it in a long time i remember
thinking it was okay at the time i
didn't like it as much as the
as the first conan arnold was in it i
got to get it
but it's it's hard to find on blu-ray
it's expensive
i kind of feel like i just saw it on
what is it on one of the streaming
services i feel like you know one of the
trainings
i remember i kind of under the
impression that it had kind of a cheat
cheap
look to it and that the writing wasn't
all that great
conan two the destroyer
it had a lot of good stuff in conan
but seriously that monster comes out of
the mirror problem was the monster that
came
out of the damn mirror every time that
happens
that's that movie could be fixed
you could enter some of those boss
fights out of there hey adam sane is
here
oh hey what's up adam from
conspiranormal um
you could edit some of those boss fights
out of that movie
and do something with cg that
probably or just maybe just reenact it
you could fix that movie but would you
make any money on it no
no that's why they haven't done it
they're just leaving it the way it was
it didn't have that [ __ ] mythic
element to cronin and the destroyers
which bums me out because i feel like
like you said we've talked about this a
lot
i feel like the conan universe
i mean the first conan was so good conan
the destroyer
had some good [ __ ] in it but overall
was kind of lackluster and then they
never really made a third one
but i feel like that needs to be a
trilogy
like i said young man middle-aged man
old man it would be like a perfect
trilogy but they have to do it
in the way that like they have the same
writer and he's writing that [ __ ] from
the beginning
and he's mapping all that ahead of time
so it all links in together three movies
that are all linked in together i think
they'll be [ __ ] brilliant well conan
one is not a movie it is the movie
okay it is the how to manual how to be a
[ __ ] badass
and it's not just men it's women too
because valeria was the female
example of she kicked out of what
womanhood was
the first story was about growth
growth growth going from [ __ ] nothing
to something that's what it was about
okay and what life's like
and that none of that shit's fair and
most people [ __ ] lose
some people are some people succeed
where others fail
because it's it's natural selection and
what is selected
well it's shown in the movie what is
selected
and then it shows all the dynamics
between men
are products of many fathers it has that
theme
okay uh women
their motivations are different than men
it's mostly told
from a from a from a a male
point of view because that's who's
writing that's mostly who's watching
but the but the female powers are also
shown okay what a woman means to a man
is escape from a life that is focused
around
death in other words it's leaving
soldiering
she tells him let's get out of here just
me and you so
she's promising valeria is promising him
eternal life and freedom from that life
in the form of marriage and a child yeah
that's the thing like
you know not so much in real life but in
fiction
um you know not so much nowadays but
back in the old days like
particularly in fantasy literature like
sci-fi stuff like that
so a woman would represent because a lot
of it was written by men
so you know it'd be like a woman
represents
getting a family getting a family life
it's like so carrying your line on
because
you know a man can't do that no only a
woman can do that so you need to like
hook
[Music]
but you have to understand the story is
told from a man's point of view well
yeah that well that's what i just said
yeah
and again from my point of view you
can't be in the army forever
yeah you gotta you gotta get a job and a
life
and get meet a woman and you know
fulfill yourself and have a [ __ ]
fulfilling relationship
have a child so when you die you've
replaced yourself
you know what i'm talking about you've
made replacements so no it's totally
true
and what is true true are things that
stand the test of time
reproduction has stood the test of time
none of you would be here
obviously that's what it's talking about
it's all i talk about the big picture
[ __ ]
but no i love that movie that is the
movie
everything about it is true it's just a
shame that they didn't make it a trilogy
because that would have been a perfect
trilogy yeah
because milius was going to go through
the stages of life
that's what i'm saying right that would
have been a perfect trilogy honestly
right and you could do that nowadays
though
like i said you could do it on netflix
you could on amazon prime you could do
like you know it was just like a three
volume movie series
right you could even shoot it all at
once if you wanted to amelia said the
third one the last one was going to be
about the repercussions of everything
that you've done
yeah yeah and see that like i said the
name of brilliant like i said i'm a
writer so it's like from my standpoint
it's like that just
it just ties everything up it'd be oh
it'd be so good
and but they never did it that's what
bums me out
i think that's what bums because i love
the first conan right i'm a girl
i love the first conan the second conan
was really a letdown because they
[ __ ] cheaped out on it yeah
they cheaped out on it and they didn't
really get into
they didn't get into this like thematic
because they
weren't i'm you know i get it they
weren't like really they were just like
oh the first coney made a lot of money
so let's make another one
they weren't really thinking about the
artistic [ __ ] behind it
like someone like me would where it's
just kind of like no man let's do a
continuation and we gotta like set it up
and it's like
we gotta do a second [ __ ] thing and
this is what we're gonna do
and they didn't really do that so it's
like let's just throw some [ __ ]
people and [ __ ] jc's halloween
costumes in there and it's like [ __ ]
oh and it became a wrestling duel
that i know and it's like it's such a
shame yeah because it was
you know adam adam sayings from saying
that it's talking about the wizard duel
yeah well it was not the same direction
not the same writers such a bummer
you're not dealing with milius
so it's going to be lightweight [ __ ]
milius was heavy
weight he was all about philosophy
and and how to [ __ ] take something
that's true
and things that have been true for
millions of years
and tell that into an into a
contemporary story
you know what i mean of the here and now
how does that impact you
you know how does truth [ __ ] with you
basically every time it's just like
every time i see
it's just kind of like okay so this is
the same thing like i said i'm a writer
and i like
[ __ ] that's like contained you know what
i mean i like a thematic
contained [ __ ] so
this like the coney and [ __ ] bums me out
the same way that dario argento's quote
unquote three mothers
trilogy bones me out because look he
made suspiria
brilliant [ __ ] movie he made inferno
a pretty good pretty good movie
and then he waited many many many many
many many years
and then he made mother of tears and it
sucked
and it didn't have anything to do with
the first two it didn't look like the
first two i was that that made me so mad
i like thematic
everything has to go together if you're
gonna make the [ __ ]
if you're gonna make a trilogy if you're
gonna make like
something it all has to go together
don't make like two movies
in 1977 and then 1980 or whatever
they make another one [ __ ] 2007 or
whatever and it's like oh this is the
third one of the trilogy it's nothing
like the other ones
don't [ __ ] do that it makes me so
angry i just i don't like it
grantham says eventually every warrior
needs to find a woman and settle down or
else tragedy happens
exactly well if you're
a [ __ ] warrior and you don't find a
woman and settle down that's probably
because you're either dead
or you're unacceptable and you're now a
bum
yeah or you don't settle down because
you're in a constant [ __ ] war
and you keep finding more and more
armies to fight for which means
eventually you're killed
with no with with nothing to carry on
your genetic code so you're taken out of
the damn
system like you never existed so yeah
if you don't do anything then there's
tragedy i honestly [ __ ] that's what
milius was saying he said it's
exactly what he's telling you well and
the thing is too i feel like that
is the exact same template of
every action movie ever i mean like the
mission impossible movies the james bond
movies
anything that i had yeah i heard
anything that had
a male action here and he was just like
i just keep fighting and fighting
and it just seems like at some point he
had to meet a woman and just like knock
it off
because i was like dude if you don't
stop fighting you die
exactly somebody else has to take your
place in that fight you'll die
and it's very waiting till death that's
very interesting to me because it's
always dudes that write these
yeah so it's like really interesting to
me like how they
because i don't you know i'm a girl so i
i see
the world like kind of differently but
it's like it's always interesting to me
like how they see
how they see things like how they write
the stories
you know what i mean like i get it like
i'm a writer so i kind of like
understand where their
where their perspective is coming from
you know what i mean
but that's it's always really
interesting to me mr robert sends a
special super chat
two dollars saying this is now old
enough to do king
conan yeah i've been looking into the
king conan is he gonna do it or no
no uh the dude from the robert e howard
[ __ ] foundation or whatever who owns
all the rights to that [ __ ]
they really didn't want to do that but
they just couldn't get it through the
hollywood system they couldn't get
backers
um it's kind of missing a
middle movie at this point yeah i was
going to say they really knew one of the
things second [ __ ]
one of the things that they thought
about was a netflix series
that had arnold in it as the old arnold
and he would narrate telling the stories
of what he did as the young arnold
so you have a young guy doing the code
and stuff
and then yeah with arnold telling you i
think that you have to do that that was
one of the things because he's too old
yeah to play the [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] up the second movie
right so they missed that opportunity so
and now it's too late that's how i would
do it they need to like start over
i would have a netflix series or some
kind of series
that's what i'm saying where old
king conan narrates and tells you
because you can't get mako to do it
anymore
because you know the sorcerer he was a
good way of you know
he was a good narrator i like that yeah
i like that guy
yeah but he's dead now i believe yeah i
think
he's gonna die unfortunately yeah well
he did he'd be in his 90s now wouldn't
he
all right yeah well unless he's still
alive in which case
w i'm not being weird just that movie
start you know
how did it go how did the [ __ ]
narration go
oh man maybe you guys can [ __ ] maybe
you guys can oh tila is talking about
the limey
oh that was so good like seriously watch
the line me it's really really good
i've seen it yeah these are the days of
high adventure
and how are you gonna get a soundtrack
like that nowadays
the [ __ ] score to conan won was app
ick [ __ ] epic
[Laughter]
you can listen to that [ __ ] on youtube
today just listen to the [ __ ] this
with [ __ ] songs this name of the song
i love
i love the score of the anvil of krom is
the [ __ ] name of the songs this [ __ ]
anvil krom yeah [ __ ] right man that's
one of the scores that i just listened
to like without even watching the movie
same with like the original suspiria
i'll listen to that [ __ ]
score all day long too without watching
the movie but yeah they don't want any
but well like i said nowadays like
arnold schwarzenegger too old obviously
but you could totally do
a three movie series somebody would pick
that up i feel like
there's a lot more chance of it now than
there was back then like i said the
first movie brilliant second movie
i would make three series and you see
here's the thing
emilius is still alive you have him
write the series
all right and so you have the young
season one is the young conan season two
is the middle age conan
season three is the old conan right and
instead of having a sort
the sorcerer would be the narrator to
all of them you have
arnold schwarzenegger as king conan yeah
he's just like talking about what had
happened sure he's telling you the whole
[ __ ] story
throughout the entire series that's how
i would do it
i mean yeah it just seems like it would
be
i don't know but you know like i said
there's so many streaming services
nowadays
dude there are like i've read
horror novels right and then after i
read them
i found out that they had been adapted
to a series
and i didn't even know about it you know
what i'm saying so there's so many
streaming services nowadays that i can't
keep up
with even [ __ ] that i like books that i
like
that have been adapted to series for
christ's sake and i didn't even [ __ ]
know about it
i read gillian flynn's sharp objects
without knowing that that had been
adapted to a [ __ ] series i think it
was for hbo
which i still haven't watched i heard it
was good the book is awesome
but the fact that that is happening i
just can't keep
up i can't keep up anymore so there's
too much good [ __ ] nowadays it's too
much good [ __ ]
any more oconee that's who did the uh
soundtrack to the uh
market yeah yes right here dude
badass [ __ ] drums in the times when
when the oceans drank atlantis what was
that
[Laughter]
i can't remember the [ __ ] monologue
when you first i can't either
yeah tila says demons is great demons
two not as good but i like them both
especially the first one
uh yeah i do like both of the demons
movies but but the first one is
like way better um no need for me says
uh i kind of on it asia argento when i
was younger
asia argento is rad
um did you guys see like i liked a lot
of the movies that she was in
although this is super creepy but she
was in [ __ ]
she did a sleepless she did stendhall
syndrome
which is still a good movie um
i kind of it's weird because daario
was real into making movies with
ozzya who was his daughter and it seemed
like he was always putting like some
rape scenes in there
so it's a little weird just saying it's
italy i'm not judging
but you know what i mean yeah that's
right tom the bosses i don't think india
did conan so
michael adam adam sane jumps in and goes
no it was basil uh pola doris that's
right
yeah that sounds more familiar and
honestly sometimes you watch the first
conan and you leave the
screen on and it's like i love that i
love
that yeah title uh music
you know yeah i don't know really
[ __ ] that was one that was one of
[ __ ] james l jones's best [ __ ]
roles
as uh he turned into a snake and
everything yeah
as [ __ ] dulce doom and dulce doom was
about
he was he was about [ __ ] cultural
marxism man
he'd get you to worry about your destiny
and what you saw in the water and
this and that and [ __ ] he didn't
worry not worried about yourself or
anything else
you're just going up in there partying
and then secretly behind the [ __ ]
behind the scenes it's a [ __ ]
never-ending
[ __ ] circular firing squad they're
eating their own
you understand it now don't you people
they were eating their own
back there they were cannibals because
they didn't grow anything you see any
crops
they couldn't make anything they just
went in the temple and ate each other
and had a big [ __ ] drug fueled orgy
and you had a [ __ ] doom up there
they also do he knew all about it he was
[ __ ] running the game he understood
it
he understood exactly what he was doing
but he thought flesh was strong
you know he thought flesh was strong and
you know he thought it was stronger than
steel it's not true
though uh obviously that's not true
flesh is not strong
looking that's the meaning of the end of
that movie conan's dad
told him that steel was strong you could
trust steel you couldn't trust women you
couldn't trust
money or other men or anything but you
could trust this steel sword
well that [ __ ] broke somebody pissed you
off you could just stab them yeah
but that [ __ ] broke the sword broke
you couldn't trust it and then [ __ ]
doom says
oh yes the riddle of steel yeah steel is
a strong flesh is strong look
come here my child she kills herself she
said that's power
that's no that's not what it was okay
conan took a broken sword and still cut
his head off with it
flesh isn't strong even a broken [ __ ]
sword can cut a hand off
what is strong what is strength what is
the riddle of steel
strength is the will to act that's all
it is
willpower that was the [ __ ] if you do
nothing then nothing happens
exactly the same lesson that [ __ ] raz
al
ghul try to teach batman over there and
[ __ ] batman begins
says no your dad got killed because it
was his fault
he failed to act and that that's
that's that that's the that is the
secret to the riddle of steel
that's all it is and it's directly out
of nietzsche
that which does not kill you makes you
stronger you must act
if you don't act you're irrelevant
that's all it means
well yeah you're right i mean like i
said
if you don't do anything then nothing
happens and you ain't [ __ ] most people
don't do anything
victor says jenny is so behind i i am i
i only have like the chat over here and
it keeps like
[ __ ] so he's like way ahead of me
yeah i
i'm [ __ ] 10 minutes ahead you
probably are like because somebody asked
me earlier
and i can't even remember what it was
now somebody was asking about now i'm
afraid to touch anything
but i'm going to roll james
jones from mississippi i think he lived
in michigan too
but his family was from mississippi
you didn't know that darth vader was
from [ __ ] mississippi just listen to
that voice man
he's afro-irish mississippi boy
and he was an army ranger too eight
snakes an
old-school army ranger xanada soldier
that you needed to watch fargo
yeah everybody's saying that i got to
see it fargo is so
good yeah i gotta see it it's so good
well like i said it's cohen brothers
it's you know oh yeah victor garcia said
jenny here's some money from the future
i've sent you five dollars thank you for
the future
right that's how it feels like because
like i said my chat is like 10 years
behind
so you know at least my shit's still
going yeah
ugh you guys i'm so frustrated
danny uh danny roland ghostface saying
that talking about the chamberlain
should do a film about the infamous
werewolf case
north umberland pennsylvania from long
ago
since all of his films take place in
pennsylvania you're just saying
who's shameless yeah although i liked
his superhero movies
yeah they're very good somebody i you
know what i
i was on amazon prime site and i saw
that they had the happening was on there
and i'm just kind of like maybe i should
watch that
i've heard that it was unintentionally
hilarious
i don't know do i really want to like
waste time on it
yeah down the bottom because darth vader
from bristol no the voice of darth vader
okay the voice of darth vader was from
mississippi
it was an army ranger from mississippi
tell me what the chat says i'm behind oh
they're just
talk uh xanada says tom uh i thought i
would like also no country for old men
i want to go through an awesome movie oh
my god you've like missed out on so much
[ __ ]
cultural [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] is your
problem
no country from old men was so good
and then uh somebody asked anybody seen
phantasm yeah we saw the whole series
yeah it's an excellent series we
reviewed the first phantasm and i think
phantasm 2.
honestly like one of these days i want
to do the whole series because
phantasm and y'all can come at me if you
want
phantasm is one of the few series
that i think every single one of them in
the like all the sequels
all good all worth watching yeah because
one they all had reg yeah and reggie
is the [ __ ] but they all did something
different
i mean okay so there's like some debate
about
which one's better like the original
phantasm or phantasm two
the first one i saw was phantasm two i
saw that in the theater
and i loved it and then later i went
back and watched the original phantasm
which is also awesome
it's like way lower budget phantasm 2
was kind of had a bigger studio behind
it so they had like a
much bigger budget so they did like some
cooler effects and stuff so
that's just kind of like to me it's kind
of a difference between
well um how will it like phantom 2 is
less weird
but it's more polished so it's kind of
like whatever you kind of feel like
but i love that the series they just
went off on a thing it's like we're just
going to do like this
[ __ ] up road trip yeah
hold on esther see all the phantasms
all of them are good they're all good
they're all good i liked all of them
yeah
and i don't say that about a lot of
franchises because like i said
let me jump in and say something the
phantasm
property was a creation
of one man one man's concept and the don
that made that helped him do this sure
it's very coherent it's very
unique uh it's a excellent world
building
um it's it's 125
fan service if you like his movies
you're gonna like him
because he's talking to you it's i think
it's one of the best properties out
there
um i put it up there with uh the
reanimator properties probably a little
bit better in terms of writing
even though i love [ __ ] jeffrey
columns i mean he's hard to beat combs
but man the phantasms all
i think there's five of them in there
yeah they're all
super enjoyable yeah they're all worth
watching and by the time you get to the
last
and and you're in a very
codified horror sci-fi
comedy adventure world
kind of like evil dead kind of like well
i feel like a lot of people don't i feel
like it
gets a little bit of short shrift
because a lot of people talk about when
you're talking about horror franchises
all right you're talking about
friday the 13th you're talking about
nightmare on elm street you're talking
about that kind of [ __ ]
um of which a lot of them were like hit
and miss
uh you know but phantasm
i feel like it doesn't get talked about
enough in the sense of
every single movie being
good being worth watching okay guys
super chat from mr roboto two dollars
how about king conan last crusade arnold
last i'm not sure exactly what you're
talking about
um king conan originally was supposed to
be
conan in his old age
having to deal with the repercussions of
his life
how does he mother how did you back then
how does a warrior get off my lawn
how does a warrior of that age remain
relevant
that's what that was the original
concept what
what does he do what what is a great
example of old age
for a man that's what it's talking about
but like i said you needed millions for
that and you missed the middle movie
they'll never make king conan well they
should have done it back then
it's too far gone i mean look at what
like okay back in the old days i know it
wasn't a thing
where it's like oh we're gonna do this
big world building and it's like you
know everybody was like extend the
universe like nowadays
back then it wasn't like that we made
one good movie and it's like oh
everybody wants more of that because
that was super so okay so we'll cobble
together
a second one so they weren't really
thinking about it but look at like
the back to the future trilogy which to
me
is kind of like the platonic ideal
of movie trilogies so they were
some people were doing it back then but
even that they weren't planning that
ahead of time
yeah exactly they just made the movie
and it was really successful so they're
like okay well we're just gonna write
another one
they didn't plan it to be a trilogy yeah
okay santa jumps in i've never heard of
these movies dude first of all
you're you're just a young kid all right
wait have you heard of what movies
phantasms you're just a young kid you
mean well
but you can't get through [ __ ] great
movies all right how are you going to
get through the [ __ ] awesome shitty
movies all right
i showed you what you needed to watch
well i mean this is what [ __ ]
this is what phantasm was phantasm one
was back and there was a 77
78 79 i think the first one
it was basically a homemade horror movie
the guy that made it starred in it
and it's just no he wasn't it well he
wasn't in that no i don't know i thought
he was in that one now
wasn't reggie in that yeah reggie was in
it but he didn't write it
he didn't write that okay he was just
like a friend of duncan he was a friend
and not okay yeah okay but he's in all
of them
i thought he was the one that was
writing them no okay
anyway the very first one
was about a dude
who ends up in a finding a [ __ ] weird
ass haunted [ __ ] mortuary
that's all i could [ __ ] say about her
dicks turns out turns out
yeah it turns out that the [ __ ] it's
a little surreal the mortuary
is a [ __ ] gateway into another
dimension
yeah and there's a bunch of characters
in involved in this story that come from
this other dimension
yeah it's kind of like the dimension of
the dead
like a hell but not really you just got
to watch it and as
each movie unfolds it gets crazier and
crazier and crazier
but it has but reggie the main character
is a real kind of lovable character
she's just funny you know i love your
head
it's kind of like ash from evil dead but
yeah he's kind of like that type of
exact uh that type yeah he's always
[ __ ] going after [ __ ] hot girls
that are half his age
[ __ ] bald he's in bad shape but
for some reason these hot babes love him
and it's just very lovable just [ __ ]
crazy you know
it's [ __ ] funny and then it gets down
to
like movie five it's almost like the
beginnings of a mad max
series that's doing homages to mad max
well like i said it turned into a road
trip maybe
even after the well the second one was
kind of like a road trip movie but like
even
like past that it kind of goes in yeah
but like i said it's interdimensional or
that like they're kind of aliens
but i don't think they're aliens i think
they're interdimensional they're just
whatever they have to be at the time
there are there does seem to be rules
and
he ends up throughout the whole movies
running around in this badass [ __ ]
car this [ __ ] badass [ __ ] muscle
car
trying to find out where the next
portal to this dimension where it
appears because they're going from town
to town
and basically taking all the people
and sucking the their energy out yeah
don't explain too much though yeah don't
worry about it don't worry about it like
i said
they're kind of surreal yeah so if
it's kind of one of those things where
it's like how much patience do you have
for surrealism
yeah the first one's very surreal the
second one was actually
pretty i saw it in the theater it was it
got a wide release and it was like kind
of a big studio behind it
so they kind of like had a bigger budget
it's still pretty weird yeah like the
the premise
they go actually but yeah but all of
them are worth watching it's one of the
few
seri one of the few properties where the
movies get better as they go
i i thought they were well because each
of them did something different it
wasn't kind of like
you know like the friday the 13th
franchise which i love the friday
i love slasher movies but it's like the
friday the 13th ones it's like after the
third or fourth one
yeah you didn't really need to watch any
of them then they're talking about
beastmaster i remember beastmaster that
was the dude that had two ferrets in the
bag
i remember liking it but i haven't been
a long time since that's on amazon prime
if you want to watch it
i just yeah tina says my uncle told me
to watch some old sinbad movies and said
they were the best back in the day yes
they were
oh i used to like those thin bad movies
yeah they were good they got
ray harryhausen [ __ ] effects stop
motion effects
um i forgot what tom baker the dude who
played one of the doctor who's was in it
uh in one of them i think that was
something oh yeah
in the eye of the tigers i think it was
the tiger yeah
they're they're good they're very good
and there's some about them that
they're british and they're kind of
sucky into them
almost kind of like a ride at disneyland
like pirates of the caribbean or
yeah it's not kind of they kind of have
like a magical
mysterious vibe to them a lot of
mythological monsters and statues coming
alive with [ __ ] swords that sinbad
has to fight and
you have to save girls who've been
turned into damn
monkeys didn't that girl get turned no
well she got shrunk down here
i think i think a prince got turned into
a monkey and had to turn him back to a
human
there's all kinds of magic involved and
sorcerers
and yeah it's good it's good they're
very good um
some my babysitter kimmy took me to see
him [ __ ]
theater when i was a little kid yeah
with my little [ __ ]
getting up next to her like that
watching him and [ __ ] his fun that
was so scary
i think i saw a sinbad in the eye of the
tiger i'm pretty sure i saw that of the
drive-in when i was little
but yeah i saw them they were good
yeah and uh what was good about them is
that they
they were british movies kind of like a
hammer horror film
they didn't they weren't filled with a
bunch of hollywood tropes
they had their own they had their own
flavor and tone to them which i thought
was mysterious and pleasant
mysterious and pleasant you know what
i'm talking about it was a mixture of
when you were a kid
scary but enjoyable yeah i liked a
lot of magic and [ __ ] but yeah your
uncle told you to watch them because
yeah they're good they're classics the
writing was really good
i love stop-motion effects yeah i love
all that ray harry has and stuff yeah he
also did i think one of the last movies
he did was clash of the titans
which is 1981 i want to say yeah which
was one of my favorite movies from when
i was a kid
i [ __ ] loved clash of the titans man
some people are saying start with
phantasm too no start with phantasm one
man see them both
well okay so the thing about it is the
difference between fantastic well two
but yeah
if you have more of a penchant for
real low-budget homemade kind of movies
start with phantasm one if you want kind
of a more slick
kind of hollywood kind of [ __ ] start
with phantasm two
because that was a bigger budget but you
miss
certain things but well i mean you can
go back and watch the first phantasm
later
i'm just saying that depending on like
what your
proclivity is like what your entry point
is gonna be
yeah um i'm just saying that phantasm
is it doesn't get enough credit for
being
all of the like i said all of the
[ __ ] movies are worth watching and i
think
almost all of them other than two
because i think the other
uh you know some bigger studio owns that
i think all of them are
might be on shutter yeah mango got it
right it was the golden boy just sitting
back that had tom baker
that's right that was a good one he
plays the evil sorcerer yeah yeah yeah
it [ __ ] knocks it out we just watched
that not too long yeah and a lot of
people you know
i know him as a doctor who you know one
of the oldest people
but it's my favorite doctor who but
seeing him as an evil [ __ ] sorcerer
was [ __ ] good
he was actually really good at that real
good um
but yeah so what was i thinking of oh
okay yeah so i was thinking about like
horror franchises
phantasm is one that doesn't really get
enough credit
for all of the [ __ ] sequels being
good
i mean look at [ __ ]
uh you know friday the 13th which
one was good two was awesome three was
awesome after that
four well four and five were good after
that
you know what i mean tina says she made
me think there were dozens of sin bads
there's only three of them
yeah i think there's three of the
british ones those are the main ones
that most people know about there might
be four
well it ends with i the tiger
i think yeah i saw that that's a good
one too well the weird thing about it is
i think there were other ones that were
made in other countries exactly the
finnish and russian ones
yeah because i saw one on mystery
science theater
they suck which was yeah finnish
yeah and they tried to make
sinbad yeah a finnish
yeah well what's the story it was like a
really it was
russian he might have been russian i
don't know i feel
like well there well okay so mystery
science theater did
a bunch of these movies that were
finnish russian co-productions yeah and
a lot of them were based on
um you know urban like legends like
folklore
from that area so you kind of had like
you had jack frost
yeah which i [ __ ] loved that episode
but they also did
sinbad uh what the [ __ ] was the name of
that i don't know but the thing is is
that
the russian sinbad the russian finnish
white was not sinbad no it was a some
kind of a russian
character who was a sailor yeah who
they had a bunch of russian stories
about him he went to find the bluebird
of happiness yeah
but what they did was they wanted to
sell that to the to the united states
and the rest
so they redubbed it and renamed renamed
him sinbad
because americans wouldn't know that
right
yeah yeah which is a huge mistake
it would have been much better to
introduce him as the russian
character that so because it didn't make
any sense to sinbad
well no because it didn't have anything
to do with the other side they didn't do
a sin bit
sinbad wasn't from [ __ ] russia not
even persian wasn't
right i think it was either persian he
was serious yeah yeah
persian or or arabian i think he was
persian
and um yeah [ __ ] this guy's
definitely
a scandinavian a russian scandinavian
scandinavian
folklore folklore story shouldn't make
any sense but
uh no the the british the british ones
that you're looking at those three
that's it right there
i watch them in order you'll like them
they're real good they were kind of like
for me as a kid
that was my first version of like star
wars they were as good as star wars when
then star wars came out and i was like
wow and then i got focused on that
but the sinbad movies were just as good
as star wars i mean honestly that
the ray harryhausen skeleton fight yeah
one of the best stop-motion sequences
what about when he [ __ ] collee
yeah that also on yeah she had she had
was it i loved that
arms yeah arms and swords and he's like
big like this big giant yeah
she started off as a statue and that
starts her attorney made her and she's
like
brought her to life and she had a
fighter and then remember he had that
and and i the tiger he reanimated that
gigantic tiger and that evil sorceress
had that
[ __ ] minotaur robot that's crazy
remember that yeah and she was uh
she didn't have enough magic but she
started off as a seagull and they lost
she lost some of the potion to turn her
back to a human so when she turned back
into a human it was
the dose wasn't quite strong enough so
she had one pit one seagull foot
remember that that's right she looked at
it
she screamed damn it she didn't have
enough [ __ ] potion to hate when i
just
transferred yeah it's pretty good that
[ __ ] sucks when that happened
yeah i think i saw i have the tiger in
the drive-in actually
yeah sinbad battling medusa i think he's
got that mistaken
for um um uh
clash of the titans clash of the titans
i don't think flash of the titans
was the la that came on 81 and that was
the last
i'm i think that was the last movie that
ray harryhausen did the
animation for question titans was good
too before he
retired but when i was growing up
clash of the titans oh my god i love
clash of clans i think that was like
what
turned me on to like greek mythology
sinbad
is greek and sinbad doesn't fight
anything greek yeah that's like
some version like he fights persian [ __ ]
and
some indian stuff he fights kali yeah a
statue of khalid it comes a lot
giant well i guess he fought a giant
golden minotaur yeah
didn't he so that's great i don't
remember him fighting a medusa
no uh he'd fight gigantic bears giant
bears
uh stop motion medusa was that was from
clash of the days wasn't it a giant bear
he fought oh you know what i don't
remember
i remember the kali i remember the
skeletons i remember
oh you know who else is in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] caroline monroe
that's right her hot ass is in the in
one of those movies i think that was
i think that was in sinbad and and the
and uh the eye of the tiger
was she the one that got shrunk i think
she originally got shot but
it's just you're going to see caroline
monroe and who is
unbelievably she's been star crashing
yeah unbelievably gorgeous
caroline monroe and she's
um in this sinbad movies i think she's
in the third one
and the whole time she's running around
and basically a basically a [ __ ]
i dream of genie costume well that was
kind of her shtick
well it was it's a persian character
yeah yeah
so yeah and she's the cleavage just like
it's british [ __ ] tailored this [ __ ]
because they're bubophiles like me too
and that [ __ ] was just going
so you're gonna see that yeah
[Laughter]
they're very boob-centric yeah they knew
the deal like i said even they're
new i don't know if it's like this
anymore but their newspaper so that was
the page three girl
yeah that was just for no reason it's
like we have a newspaper but on page
three we just have a
chick with their tits hanging out see
there you go different chick every week
t's going all right might get my popcorn
ready for a weekend
[Laughter]
yeah what was the one that was the one
that was on mystery science theater
mango says she was in golden voyage okay
yeah yeah okay there you go
yeah i get them all confused what are
the names you had
it was well i remember i had tiger
because i saw that at three yeah that
was the last one and then golden voyage
i think was the middle one and the first
one was called
sinbad and this something sees
and the something something seven c's
maybe
mango tell me tell me write them down
what the i'm gonna watch this
we need to re-watch those again yeah we
went to we watched someone with tom
baker like not too long
yeah because i remember watching that i
think that was golden boy just in bed
but
like i said there were some there were
some
russian slash finish co-productions
that were based on russian folklore or
scandinavian folklore but when they
tried to sell them to the u.s
they dubbed them in english and then
they named them
sinbad and the something or other even
though it was clearly not
sinbad like you said and one a couple of
these
turned up on mystery science theater
like i said one of them was jack frost
seventh boy just said bad yeah that was
the that was the first one and then it
was
sinbed and the what's that gold golden
voyage of sin bad and then [ __ ]
sinbad in the eye of the tiger yeah yeah
they're good
real good i just remember seeing sinbad
in the eye of the tiger like at the
drive-in
yeah and then i remember
i don't know because i remember like
this was like a little bit before that
duran duran album
seven and the raga tiger came out so it
all was kind of like
blending together in my mind i wish i
could remember the name of that [ __ ]
what was the [ __ ] was that movie they
did on mst it was sinbad and something
rather
but it obviously wasn't sinbad it was
like [ __ ] it was some scandinavian
[ __ ]
and they even made a lot of jokes about
it being like everyone just being like
white as [ __ ] and i can't
and i can't remember what it was but it
was like super funny
i don't know whatever but um yeah
i'm so behind on the chat you guys i'm
so sorry
yeah caroline monroe was in maniac i had
totally forgotten
i just rewatched maniac probably like a
month or two ago i saw it a long time
ago and then i rewatched it
and i had totally forgotten she was
saying she wasn't [ __ ] everything
[ __ ] she was one of those people that
just like kept turning up in movies and
i don't know
it was just kind of like when we watched
because uh
we recorded a review
yesterday for piranha the 1978 one
directed by joe dante and i saw that
when i was a kid
and i had forgotten how many [ __ ]
famous ass people were in that
every single person that was in that i
recognized them
and i didn't realize that at the time
because i saw it when i was probably
seven or eight years old and i didn't
know
you know who any of these [ __ ] were
so
it was like really weird watching it and
i'm like oh my god it's that guy oh my
god it's that chick oh my god it's that
it's okay or everybody in it was famous
and then we after we watched the 1978
one it was on to be
and then we watched the 1995 one
because why not it was right there and
it was free so we watched it which i
didn't even know existed until
the day we watched it so we watched the
1995 one and that was also full of
famous people i'm like
hey it's that guy from house hey it's
that chick she was in christine hey is
this
hey it's that chick from punky brewster
hey it's this you
it's crazy it's crazy it's almost nine
o'clock is it really
yeah yeah we went on this has been going
on for thirty three hours and
i can't believe that this dream has held
out that long i can't believe it
i'm getting hungry you want uh some
meatballs yeah i'm starving
all right and starving yeah we saw the
piranha movies they were good
yeah we're gonna look we uh recorded a
review
of the 78 one and we also talked about
the 95 one
yeah which we also watched because why
not yeah t says that she also added
jason in the argonauts that's a good one
oh
i like chasing them yeah you can watch
that right along with [ __ ] sinbad
what they're they're they're all about
the same i'd probably watch jason the
argonauts
last gopro go for [ __ ] sinbad first
watch all three of them and then check
out
honestly ray harryhausen i would rather
watch
stop motion animation than cgi
yeah pretty much
depends on the tone of the movie pretty
much across i mean it was terminator one
had some
of it yeah you know well uh so did
robocop
yeah robocop the uh the robot the
the one that like shot all the people in
the boardroom that was stop motion
yeah um it can be done well and like i
said you can make a whole [ __ ] movie
look at look at the dude like look at
nick park that made all the wallace and
grommet movies that's all stop motion
and that looks
amazing yeah and look at like nightmare
before christmas also amazing jason the
argonauts was good another one
another one i think it might have been
from the same move from the same
theater from the same studio was a
british movie
about some british guys that get picked
up by a german u-boat
during the war as prisoners and the
u-boat gets
lost and they end up in some kind of
[ __ ] forgotten world
that was like uh a semi-prehistoric it
had like cavemen and samurai
and [ __ ] dinosaurs what was it
called the land of time forgot maybe
yeah land the time for god i think is
what it was called
that was a good one peter cushing was
the night peter cushing was in peter
cushing
and uh doug mcclure i think so yeah yeah
i saw that one in the theater
mcclure who was then humanoids from the
deep it also had tor johnson
that's right i forgot he was in that
core johnson oh my god [ __ ] tour
he played from all the edward movies
yeah and when they get to terror
it looks like a frank fazetta painting
he's like this big old fat evil [ __ ]
king
king of these weird [ __ ] uh samurai
wearing burned up [ __ ] it was
it was pretty cool
pretty cool yeah i think that might have
had caroline monroe in it too
it's a possibility uh yeah she think it
did yeah i'm pretty sure she was
her hot ass i had forgotten that torah
johnson was in that yeah
well because i think did like the new
mst did it right like when they were on
netflix for a serie for a season and a
half i'm pretty sure they did land time
for that
yeah yeah they were like uh doug mcclure
and peter cushing build
a essentially a um
submarine slash drill except it's like
going into the earth
and they go into the middle of the earth
and
there's a bunch of like dinosaurs and
cavemen yeah see how these british dudes
are tripping that i know that [ __ ]
yeah man they're all going yeah atlanta
time for god that's the top of the [ __ ]
that was the top of the book
i know i love that movie that's a good
movie and like i saw them as a
they bring back memories i saw him as a
little kid in the theater and i had my
[ __ ]
little babysitter with me who looked
like princess leia little kimmy
we were watching this [ __ ] i got to get
a picture of kimmy cause she was cute
she was cute as [ __ ] i got a picture of
her when she's probably about 13
around her somewhere i think he showed
that on the show yeah that's that she
was she was my babysitter she looked
like
she looked like princess leia with long
hair
um but yeah [ __ ] that kind of brings
back memories of that
those movies were great to see in the
theater when you were a kid [ __ ] man
i love all those old fun as [ __ ] i love
the hammer movies i love all the amicus
movies
i love all the [ __ ] movies that were
like based on [ __ ]
yeah what's that dude's name like dennis
wheatley like the devil rides out i love
the crater mass movies i love all the
aspects i love all that [ __ ] yeah
i love that [ __ ] but the the the british
ones the [ __ ] sin bad ones and
[ __ ] land of time forgot
no it's a journey to the center of the
earth that's all that went to
where the [ __ ] peter cushing goes
down the center of the earth in a damn
boring machine
that was pretty cheap but it was still
fun the british
the british back in the 70s knew how to
entertain an audience they would take
you to another world
where you could kind of suspend your
disbelief and go into another
kind of fictional not all the time but
those movies i just mentioned they were
they were cool like that
yeah yeah tila says piranha is so good
yeah we saw they're good i could not
believe because i saw it when i was a
kid
scared the crap out of me because like i
said i'm scared of sharks and piranhas
and all that kind of [ __ ]
because i grew up right next to the
ocean um
so i hadn't seen it when i was a kid and
we watched it again and i was like oh my
god i forgot how [ __ ] good that movie
was
it's actually like a competent for some
reason i had it in my head that it was
like this cheap jack like [ __ ]
[ __ ] movie but it's really not
promised her uncle she'd watch squirm
too yeah yeah oh but uh mystery science
theater did that
yeah that was their second to last
episode when they were on sci-fi
and one the squirm episode is one of
their best episodes i think
um it's a ridiculous movie now the one
that they did on mst it's a good movie
in its own right okay i'll give it that
i mean it's cheesy it's like one of
those nature run of mock movies which i
kind of love
from that era um the mst version they
cut some [ __ ] out they cut some nudity
out they cut out
some of the gore but not all of it
because like i said they had to cut it
for time and content or whatever
but i don't know you could watch either
version
the mst version is very very funny but
the movie on its own is pretty
entertaining yeah well it's pretty
entertaining on its own just because
it's set i mean everyone
in this movie is like
ridiculously southern i mean
and the funny thing is like they did
this movie
and the dude i i think it was like
[ __ ] servo that made the joke because
like the
the chick is like um and she was like
talking and he was like come on no one's
that southern
and it it was it was just kind of like
she was like really overdoing it but it
was like
it's really really funny but the thing
fake accent um
i don't know if it was baby but it was
set
in it was supposed to be set in georgia
fly creek
that was the name of the town yeah like
my creek george like there's a town's
name fly creek
why creek georgia that's what they might
be i think they did shooting
actually there might be a place called
like they might be talking about
mayflies
well that's what i thought i mean you
know i've been to georgia so
yeah but yeah it's just it's a funny
i don't know i thought it was very funny
i really like
when on mst when they have like the
super super
southern or super super
midwest because they're all mostly
uh midwesterners other than bill corbett
who did crow like later he's from uh
new york city but other than that
they're all from the midwest
so it's like any time they did like
midwest type of movies like giant spider
invasion which was like super wisconsin
or whenever they had southern movies
like boggy creek or squirm or something
were like comedy [ __ ] gold
they're asking you to do a southern draw
if you can i don't think you can i don't
think she can
she didn't grow up that way i did but
well
all my family talked like that but i
didn't talk like she refused to be that
way
yeah well she refused it it wasn't
you'd have to [ __ ] get her mad
probably and it might come out
yeah if i got mad wrong yeah well my dad
said to the family talk like that
do you remember that do you guys
remember um
a movie called food of the gods yeah
yeah food of the gods
like i said very loosely based on the
h.g wells story
very loosely and think of some other
[ __ ] weird ones from that time
i well and i said this on the piranha
review which like i said you guys will
see in a day or two
but i love all the 70s
nature animals run amok like stories i
love like kingdom and spiders i love the
swarm
i love orca i love all of those [ __ ]
cheesy
grizzly i love all this [ __ ] book i
don't know i just there's something
about this movie that i just [ __ ]
love
what hit nine o'clock let's go ahead and
[ __ ] call you tonight yeah i'm gonna
make something to eat
everybody seems to be having fun but we
need we've been streaming for a long
time yeah yeah i can't believe well
yeah with the rats yeah the rats the big
chicken
i forgot about the big chicken yeah the
big chicken we need to do night of the
leapus
about the giant bunny rabbit i didn't
see it you didn't see nine of them
no i didn't see it night of the leap is
about giant bunny
it's so funny because it's like
obviously they're trying to make
big bunny rabbits seem intimidating and
you're just like you can't because like
they're little noses they're just like
go do it
it's like oh they're just so cute even
when they're giant
oh my god it's eating me no it's not
eating you it's just like [ __ ] cute
that'd be like if pookie grew to like
giant size and you try to make her
intimidating it's not working
it's not working she's still cute i want
to have jenny do a senator oh okay so
you're yeah you're way ahead of me i can
kind of
like i don't know and the weird thing
about it is that
when i've been to other cities like
about
you know other cities up north where
i've been like uh overseas
people thought that i sounded southern
or
thought i sounded red hecky but
i don't know i don't think i sound like
that i also because my dad's side of the
family is southern but my mom's side of
the family is from
uh baltimore so i kind of had like a
north
and a south and so i think it like
evened out
plus i didn't really want to sound like
a redneck
so i can't if i want to but i'm not
going to do it
i'm just in and out of it i didn't think
about it depending on where i was if i'm
away from the south for a long time it
starts to fade you sound like it more
than me
even though you didn't even grow up here
and i did yeah but no i mean
it's just something about well no i had
it i had a southern accent even when i
was away from the south it's just that
it gets
it gets like less you know
it fades but you've heard me on the
phone with my dad
yeah the more you talk to your dad the
more thought you found
which i probably would do that too
because i kind of tend to pick up
the uh voice patterns of people and
really because when i was in the uk for
a while i started picking up
yeah uh it's a little bit of a welsh
accent because when i came back everyone
said that i talked funny
it's subconscious it just happens
because the people around you are
talking that way and it just that's what
i'm thinking
it's like yeah and another thing is is
you know i i'll just slide into
portuguese
speaking portuguese and uh
if i speak portuguese for too long and
then i start talking to brazilians in
english and they're speaking to me in an
english act
into a brazilian accent english in a
brazilian accent
i'll start to [ __ ] sometimes respond
to them in an english act
excuse me in a portuguese or a brazilian
accent yeah
which is coming back from brazil i had a
slightly
brazilian accent to my english for a
little while then it went away
yeah well as i said it's you kind of
like
talk the way other people around you
you're talking
you know yeah which you know
uh tom petty was from gainesville and
everyone in his family had thick
southern accents except him
yeah gainesville is
not that far from here actually i've
been there a couple of times
grant this says how come in florida and
north is south and south is north
okay florida's the panhandle is just
like mississippi at alabama
it's like alabama central florida
is kind of like tennessee well central
florida
it's not like anything because
everybody's from somewhere else
except yeah well that's tennessee yeah
okay it's kind of like
the tennessee nashville area where it's
southern but there's people that have
moved there
yeah when you get down to miami
miami is heavily hispanic okay it's it's
cubans
and everybody else largely cuban yeah
florida has
always been that way this started off as
spanish territory
so they didn't they did not immigrate
here
they were they were born they've been
here been here for before generations
before the united states existed they
were already here
so then you had in the miami area
miami is kind of like the rich people
neighborhood for new yorkers
a lot of new yorkers own homes and in
several homes here
uh so you go down to miami some of those
neighborhoods are [ __ ] very
rich people from new york or very rich
people from the la
california area so they're not really
from here they just own property here
um during the 80s during the miami vice
era
miami was that miami skyline was [ __ ]
built on cocaine it just was you have to
be honest
about things this was a [ __ ] point of
entry for [ __ ] cocaine and then just
that place just exploded
and you know local government was
involved in it they knew
uh all the [ __ ] families so
the united states is going through a lot
of the united states is going through
[ __ ] changes right now but that's all
pie in the sky
you trying to chase change in south
florida is like changing mexico those
cartels will [ __ ] kill you
it's going to be like that that's why
that's why whatever rules the united
states makes it's not gonna really apply
down there
they're gonna do what they want well
they got the dirt on everybody
florida i mean from my experience and i
was born here
um florida is kind of like three states
in one
yeah the northern part of florida other
than jacksonville
um is kind of like alabama it's very
rednecky it's very
very southern you kind of get a little
bit of that bleeding in downtown
central uh part two because like i said
daytona beach where i grew up was very
rednecky also because we have nascar
tracks
yeah when you think of daytona you think
that would be like some kind of [ __ ]
metropolitan place no it's not no it's
not at all it's
i like it it's country though it's like
a big country suburb
with a beach with a with the nice so you
have like a lot of tourists
like spring break a lot of people go
there for spring break
um and there's a lot there's a big biker
culture yeah there's a big nascar
culture
it's very very rednecky yeah it's better
than it used to be when i was growing up
but it's still very rednecky yeah and
bikers are like something out of walking
dead around here
yeah i mean florida orlando tampa
is a lot more you know you it
it's kind of like harder to get a handle
on because everybody's from somewhere
else
tampa has a little bit more of like a
cuban
influence um orlando is just kind of
all over the place we have everybody
from everywhere
moves here there's a little vietnam
there's a little
there's a little everything there's a
chinatown there's a little you know what
i mean so there's like
people from everywhere and like i said
tampa is kind of like that too but it's
a little more cuban leaning they have
like a pirate thing going on
miami is pretty much like cuban
and rich white people promote north yes
well how come
how come flora floridians [ __ ] litter
so much i don't know you're talking
about mass places spotlessly clean
well no that depends on where you go
that's where you go that depends on
where you go this area is
the uh the orlando area and a lot of the
places
feels like an extension of disney theme
parks
manicured [ __ ] well at least where we
live like i said not everywhere in
florida is like that well
you get out of there you know what i
mean it's just country homes yeah it
depends on where it is some places are
older than other places
this place is very new where we are
right now and
there's no reason to go to those places
utah there's nothing there
yeah you know nothing to speak of
there's not even good restaurants over
there
no need for me says uh that
that they would have pegged me as a
northern
you can't i'm not though i'm from here
i mean like i said it's kind of like i
grew up she lived in england and [ __ ]
though too
yeah but i mean you know i i was born in
florida
i grew up in florida and my father's
side of the family
is southern uh they're from tennessee
and then they moved to florida in the
50s
and but my mom's side of the family is
more northern they're more
maryland dc type of area which i guess
is sort of northern
um but i don't know i never really
related all that much i like some
southern [ __ ] but i never really related
that much to the
culture so maybe that's why grantham
said that he was at merritt island you
couldn't believe the litter ever where
the hell's merritt island
that's over on that's um over near the
coast yeah i know where that is i don't
know that is
yeah never been there i've been there is
it
not a lot of litter there i don't know
i've been there like all that much
but yeah that's that's i haven't noticed
anything yeah but
we live in a really yeah and drove
through clear water and it was [ __ ]
spotless all them damn
[ __ ] scientologists they own that
place
that place creeped me out yeah do you
know what i mean
towards eustis it's just houses out in
the country and fields and farms and
horse farms and
if you ever want to feel like what it's
like to live an invasion of the body
snatchers go to clearwater
yeah and drive around downtown
see how that makes you feel well that's
how i feel because i lived there for
eight months and it's like that's how i
felt
it felt like invasion of the body
snatchers what's funny is that you can
just
hit this road right here and go out in
20 minutes just drive 20 minutes 20
minutes later
it feels like you're in mississippi yeah
like it's just
farms same thing farmer but houses and
there's
and you go to the center town you go to
their to their to the centers of their
towns and it's just like
a bp and uh
like maybe a daycare center and uh
a [ __ ] dollar store they got those we
actually
those [ __ ] are everywhere they're
just [ __ ] everywhere well and the
thing too
is that i mean like i said when we drive
out to my mom's house
and she lives in ocala like near the
ocala national forest
which is only really about an hour and
20 minutes from here
but honestly you drive about 20 minutes
30 minutes away from here
and it's nothing it's just like
foreign forest it's a road and
woods yeah and springs and campgrounds
and [ __ ] like that there's like nothing
out there and
the cell service is kind of spotty which
is why i don't like to drive out there
by myself because like i said if i drive
back at night and my car breaks down i'm
going to get murdered
so you know just like the movies
the united states is not very pop not
not as sparsely
populated it's not dense
what's funny is that it once heard that
you could take um
the entire world's population and it
would comfortably fit inside texas
and you'd with with everything that they
need for support
too that includes india and china
and we don't have anywhere near that
population and it's just spread out in a
pretty big area
we population densities all in these
cities
everything else is just like [ __ ]
country it's real [ __ ] sparse
yeah i mean you know it's around here
it's not like
i mean i see people every day obviously
but yeah
and the cities are nowhere as dense as
say like tokyo nothing like that
and when you say city areas you look if
you actually look at
google earth they're not in the downtown
areas they're more like in suburban
sprawl around the downtown
well like i said people [ __ ] people
[ __ ] about new york being crowded
go to london and then get back to me
yeah
yeah it's not like that because it's
like i you know i'm i'm not a big like
people person i don't like a lot of
crowding but i love new york i was in
london i love london too but it's like i
was in london like holy crap this is
like [ __ ]
a hundred times worse than like way more
crowded than new york was
like in the sense of like going in a
store and just being like uh
just like kind of fighting through
people and stuff it's probably not like
that now but it was like that in the 90s
and two victor says that's already
happening in texas yeah it probably is
everybody's moving to texas everybody's
moving to texas and florida
well yeah but that's why they're
building all new [ __ ] houses i think
they're mostly going to the miami area
though
i-4 corridor we are where we are they're
we're picking up some but
i think i think most of yeah because
they are building a lot of new [ __ ]
around here but that's been going on for
as long as i can remember the average
person who doesn't really [ __ ] know
much about florida maybe they have a
whole bunch of money in their pockets
they're going to go to miami because
that's what everybody's where everybody
else is
well miami and orlando are the two
places that everybody
knows out of the two i'd pick orlando
you can get a lot more for your money
here and i just like it better than
well the thing about orlando is that
it's a nice
it's a nice downtown area it's not
massive
but it still has like some cool [ __ ]
that you expect from a downtown area
but there's a lot of you know excerpts
like suburbs
that are not horribly expensive and you
can usually i mean you got to watch
because there's like some [ __ ]
sketchy areas around here too
but you have to like but you can get a
lot for your money down here
in the orlando area if you don't want to
live like right in downtown because
obviously that's expensive
yeah but if you have a million dollars
to spend
you can get a gigantic match and you can
get something that you you never
get something like that for a million in
california i mean
i saw glenn danzig's house and it was
quoted at nearly a million and that old
[ __ ] dump
you know what i mean and that was like
something that was up the road for where
i would live [ __ ] when i was living
in carson
and i was just like that's a that's what
a million gets you in [ __ ]
college well like i mentioned before
it's like you could get if you had
four hundred thousand dollars you could
get a really nice house for that
four bedrooms in this area brand new
house because i think
this house which is probably 11 or 12
years old this is four bedroom three
bath i think it's like
1400 square feet something 1500
something like that a million to get you
a mansion right over here and this
is less than 400 thousand dollars like i
said but and you could probably they
just built some newer houses that are
about the same size and style as this
and i think they're between four and
five hundred thousand yeah and they look
like little
like little and some of them are a
little bit bigger than those they look
like little spanish castles
they got little [ __ ] yeah they got a
little current round
everything they just built a brand new
neighborhood like a year or two ago
like just right up the stream it looked
like [ __ ] disney
walt disney's interpretation of what a
spanish castle
they're cute the houses are nice though
yeah and it's nice because
i don't really like the frontage because
it seems like that road is kind of a
[ __ ] to get
uh you know on and off of but the back
of it is nice because it
you know the back of it is like right on
that trail
so you get like all the trees in the
back it's kind of like nature
tina says a million dollar home in
silicon valley make you laugh yeah i
know
i don't understand it you don't have to
live anywhere everybody can work online
i mean you can you can work a job you
can pre those silicon valley jobs don't
you bet you could do that from home
well yeah all that kind of and then that
means you could do that from florida
what the [ __ ] you need to be living in
silicon valley for elections
i've i've said this before people before
on the show i believe that
highly congested metropolitan areas are
now obsolete
i think they're technologically obsolete
it's only a matter of time before
the population density declines in those
areas and everything becomes kind of
like a developed suburbia
which well that'll be fine uh you could
have not because we got nice restaurants
out here
it's as good as anything you find in
[ __ ] boston or new york
we got that here and it's just like the
neighborhood restaurant it's
everything's spread out now there's no
reason i mean you can't walk to
you've got to be yeah you got to drive
but everybody has cars and cars aren't
expensive here you can get a car for 500
bucks here
it looks like [ __ ] but it get old 500
taurus yeah my car looks like yeah
yeah i just kind of started i just spent
230 putting two new tires yeah
so it's just my car is [ __ ] old
centralization
centralization is is technologically
obsolete
everyone's going to spread out and life
will be a lot better
you know because well like i said you
can now get everything anywhere
well we're kind of in a good area here
because
it's a nice neighborhood and
it's like it's sort of it's not
rural but it sort of feels rural in the
sense that it's kind of quiet
there's kind of woods there's a nice
trail behind it
that you can walk and it kind of seems
like it's not in the middle of
everything but then like a mile away is
the highway
a mile away there's a walgreens there's
a mcdonald's there's a
grocery store there's restaurants
there's a movie theater there's all kind
of [ __ ] like right there
you know what i mean so it's you're kind
of out in the woods
but not yeah you know what i mean so it
seems like a good
yeah victor said metro areas keep
growing though i'd have to see the
numbers
and everything is temporary nothing's
permanent
everything is is constantly shifting
and the only thing that's true are
things that last forever if it's
not forever then it's only a temporary
status
there's no reason to move to those areas
if people are moving there
there's a reason so you have to ask us
what is the reason
are they porn are they giving them free
money is that why they're going
because that'll dry up it's just i have
to see the actual data
zac asked how big of a problem or spider
is down there
yeah yeah outside the [ __ ] in the
country they're
bad um i've [ __ ] seen tarantula
things that [ __ ] big hunting spiders
there are like black widows and stuff
here but it's like honestly i think
in my entire life and i've lived here my
entire life i've only seen a black widow
maybe three times now my brother
got bit by a brown recluse spider and
got blood poisoning
that was like several years ago but i
think we were out in the woods we were
like at a spring or something so it
wasn't like
it came in the house and bit it's like a
bit his knee but we were out at um
i think we were out camping and he got
bit yeah so you do kind of got to watch
but it's not we don't get a lot of
it in the house though right well and i
feel like we have cats too so it's like
as soon as a spider comes in like a
cattle you don't
eat it so
speaking of which i walked into the
kitchen earlier
and i'm pretty sure that for a split
second
i saw a lizard that should
that then just ran under the oven yes
there is a lizard underneath the eye
okay
i thought i was like imagining things no
he came in
okay he came in through the sliding
glass door and i couldn't catch him and
he [ __ ] went oh that very [ __ ] head
yeah he doesn't he's missing a tail yes
yes
okay i just saw him for a second i was
like wait did i even see that
all right grandpa's asking about
poisonous snakes the whole time i've
been here once seen one poisonous snake
it was a coral snake
and he was only about a foot long and i
was cleaning out a horse stall with a
[ __ ] fork and [ __ ] he came up out
of there and i said what the [ __ ] are
you doing here
and i said red and yellow killed a
fellow red and black friend of jack and
said that's a [ __ ] coral snake
yeah but their heads are so small they
can't and that
they can't open their mouths wide enough
to [ __ ] bite you
they're fine yeah their fangs are in the
back of their
mouth and they uh they eat little bugs
eat crickets and [ __ ]
they're they're too yeah they're not big
they're not big i mean i had one okay
so i've lived in florida my whole life
i saw one time at my grandmother's house
i was going down her back steps and a
coral snake
went over my foot it didn't bite me it
just kind of went hey
just going over here and i was like oh
well okay that's poisonous
but he was kind of small um so i saw
that
i've seen water moccasins um and i
also saw a uh diamondback
rattler on the side of the road one time
just when i was walking home from the
mall
but he had been hit by a car yeah so he
wasn't in any shape
to bite me um other than that
i don't know you got to watch like
the the only thing you get to watch
because sk snakes are scared of people
obviously because they're much larger
than you but the so the only thing that
you have to watch is that when you're
doing like
yard work because a couple times like my
grandma would be like out cutting her
[ __ ] hedges or whatever
and then like a snake would pop out like
hey you're cutting my [ __ ] house or
whatever and then
like you know you have to watch that
because they'll bite you
if you [ __ ] with them if you don't [ __ ]
with them
usually that's like hey you're bigger
than me i'm just gonna go hide that's
what they would usually do
yeah there are four types of poisonous
snakes that live in florida
you got your water moccasins you got
your coral snakes you got your
diamondback rattlers and what's the
other one
uh i can't remember what the other one
is but there's a fourth one too
so there are four of them but they don't
like people
so as long as you don't come across them
accidentally
when you're doing yard work which does
happen um
just don't [ __ ] with them because most
people they get bit here
they get bit when they try to be [ __ ]
cute
and it's look i'm gonna pick it up and
then they bite you
yeah you know what i mean we've been
streaming forever jenny we gotta get off
okay i'm [ __ ] starving it's probably
close to 10.
yeah we've we've been on for almost four
hours yeah
holy [ __ ] go ahead and go ahead and shut
it down it's good
all right yeah let's eat something yes i
probably have to go to the bathroom
again
all right and this like wig's starting
to give me a headache
the wig the wig well it's heavy yeah you
know i mean you don't like really think
about it and then i'm like oh my god my
head hurts
all right so you guys my chat's behind
so i can't see
what you guys are they're talking to
talking about okay so
we'll be back on friday night i'm very
excited about the friday night show
because we're doing
a revisit of the satanic panic it's
gonna be a good show
oh i'm so excited yeah i've been i've
been doing like research all week
because i'm so excited about like
talking about it because
like like i said one of my favorite
topics we're gonna revisit some of the
old topics back into the when we did it
on the old format we could do a
lot better now so yeah we're gonna get
satanic panic that was one of our top
shows yeah that was our that was episode
two
like from almost five years ago yeah so
i'm very excited to like be revisiting
that so we're going to do that on friday
night at
6 00 p.m so hopefully you guys will
we'll see you later i'm sure they will
we're all saying goodbye because they
always do
all right so have a good rest of your
evening and we will see you guys on
friday night enjoy [ __ ] enjoy um
sinbad yeah go watch it i wouldn't mind
seeing some bad tonight
uh okay okay i don't care i'll be
watching i'll
i'll have some meatballs make some
meatballs and watch sandbags and drink
some beer and watch something
bad and seven voyages are simba yeah why
not all right all right so we will see
you guys on friday night
thanks for dropping by thanks for all
your super chats and
good night